hey there my wife is so mirror art she's
doing
I did a little writing here get it out of my
head
and if I should go on stage this quarter.
I need to put that there I guess
still up I took a nap I'm up again
calendar
I don't have a schedule and I never will
I'm just going and I have work since then I
have my weekends other than the Saturday and
Sunday times that are on the schedule right
now and I'll try really hard to keep those
Oasis make sure you get notifications on
because that's going to be the best way to
know I mean come on I can't schedule like
every aspect of my life all if I do today
okay I'm going to schedule a 2:30 on
Saturday I'm going to go play DotA
I go back and forth for that all the time
oh I know I'm not yelling and I mad
to see life nice
maybe a religious Allowed no a practical
over a theoretical education
how about we got this education practical or
theoretical
University fall 2017 radical knowledge of
any practical application of the knowledge
many would argue that the primary purpose of
colleges and even to get a job
to develop you as a person snnc
huge focus on the blarts
this Focus run so deep did he play in the
academic world
that for a long time
and still somewhat today
telling someone practical is
an academic slur
that's fucked up
I know for real
has been slurring the academic world
practical physicist
are people who play with toys
as opposed to the chalk
just inhaling
porn tickle physicist
Particle Fever
this distinction is well Illustrated
and the documentary
Particle Fever
you think about it
horror moment there's really only one
conclusion to make
supposed to learn the skills
the skills that will keep them and their
families alive
if it isn't at the school where they have
spent
hundreds of thousands of dollars and hours
learning
answer that question is nebulous at best
Sir Ken Robinson suggest
that the problem with creativity
rests with the fact I see the problem
stems from the fact that's it
entire educational system
is designed to produce more academics
was designed by akademiks
in order to create more
or academics
they have managed to sway social opinion
against mentorship and trade schools
or practical skills knowledge
and abilities are learns
that's fucked up
when people start to ask
how am I going to get job at the end
near the end near the end of their college
college is most colleges just give that lip
service
or send them to the placement
advisors I remember doing that
and coming up completely empty
they focus mostly on creating
connections with alumni and having and
gilding the alumni
then into offering jobs to deodorant
typically trained
new graduates
Perkiomen universities are becoming more
practical and I've already completed I think
it should yeah
butbut but these graduates don't deserve the
jobs
because they just don't qualify
in some cases
unqualified people get the job because of
their connections and school
which is even worse
answer to this the solution
has to be a shift toward
practical skills education
Within These organizations beginning
even well before College
younger grade schools children are
encouraged
to explore play an experiment
but eventually
this is changed to do what I say
or what the book says to do without
understanding why that
applies to the world
am I I'm not high I'm just talking really
slowly while right
I can't get high
I'm not high I'm just talkin really slowly
no I'm drinking coffee
how is it the same griffing he tends to be
high
you're not supposed to talk about that stuff
this has to be is yeah
he banned me for no reason one day I went in
there I was like oh I'm bad oh great
he's pretty bad he's pretty he's pretty bad
happy he seems like a decent dude but he's
just he's pretty bad happy
identity I don't know if there's something
wrong with him he's I don't want to talk
negatively about it might I feel bad
actually that you ban me but whatever
we want us to be want to voice
we want to avoid in a streamer drama I talk
on my on my stream Place yeah I know it's
mine
this is she was being asked me a shift for
practical skills education with these
organizations
Your Grace goes are in her grade school
students
I'm pretty sure sportflex permit eventually
this is changed to do what I say
and by the time these kids get to college
playing around with something to learn about
it
is frowned upon that field trips
shrimps and
as does the laughter and learning
if we are to help turn
this around I have to embrace
very messy experimentation and
I believe the best way I can contribute
to this is to capture the what
if you capture a list of things
people ought to learn for a given occupation
and then provide a way for learning
communities
remembers
learning communities to share their own
exploration
and discovery
as as they solve
I used to call to call this
delivery driven education but
I call it other things before
how's it going he meant j.p.
I think I think try to hack boxing and track
me are very you know it's funny hackers get
this
the hacker community in general totally gets
so because you can't packing is 100%
practical
I'm glad you mentioned that there is one
community
that we can turn to 4 proof
that practical application
exploration and Discovery works
phenomenally well hackers
variax of hacking is 100% practical
it is about failure and and discovery
it's about trying this and that
and then it's about applying that hack for
whatever purpose
those that excel in the hacking world
have embraced that are the new X
Athen of reading
researching writing about it
an Explorer X Lorraine experimenting
and ultimately exposing exposing
exposing their discoveries
Perhaps Perhaps this is the reason the
hacker mentality
is so fucking despised by the academic world
I don't care why it works
I just pwned your system because of it
that's dope ice skate House of crashed
might not get a new but I got to get a new
deck my deck is like trusting them trucks
rusting out on it I got to get a new deck
for it on the top to you
yeah oh yeah right
yeah that's your point that's a lot harshly
stated one of the hacker
learns Theory it is to explain
why they were able to hack something
in the most minimal terms
really fantastic yai my skates girls are not
as good as they were so I just saw them when
I can
yeah yeah
do you know what the most hackers don't care
about why they are there in most hackers
just want the Practical result and I don't
give a shit and it works the ones who care
about wiring was getting paid to patch it
and fix it
and that's different right but yeah
is the cast of list of things people ask
them for giving come I can face you in that
provide a way for me to share their own
exploration discovery
I thought many things before
Iowa putting these requirements is
prevents in the language of job listings as
open credentials
is my focus
with the open
it is designed after the most successful
learning program practical learning program
I've experienced
the Marriott badge
system of the
Boy Scouts of America really got as exposed
yep yeah
yeah satlink ocms
that's all all right I'm going to publish
that one and then
we need to I need to come back to the to the
to the thing
or should we say learning lab know twerking
now
I think we need to talk I think I'm going to
keep on the same one
alright so
I need the stuff I may be doing right now is
pretty boring but some welcome your input on
it
hi Tony
ocms
I'm for criticism or to make CG
yeah we've been talking about that and I
want to talk about the awesomest system for
a bit
yeah I do not know zardes
who is Darkness the Batman
I think I'm saying that there's an
overemphasis on theory in education and
people come out of that not being able to do
anything
I think that's the problem
Arizona College
oncologist education platform for students
those interested parties to learn about
practical or cyber security Concepts
a blue belt I see a neurologist practice
makes perfect absolutely sounds fantastic
can I get an Arizona State Department issues
a security system security really
everybody's videos I haven't heard of this
this is so different today I learned thank
you for bringing it up
ASU is Rebecca my son got a full-ride
scholarship there and turn it down
yeah how's it going cool
practical stuff make you fall in love with
their EOS interesting like that yeah
the Valkyries are to go to ASUto go to S you
fucking kidding me
how are they asking your political using it
in a card I mean that's fair it's not a
private school Louis Estate School
do anything are good new grads yeah
and the whole sister whole society Nick one
of your gateway into sports analytics really
Nick was it overly conservative there did
they ask you like what your political
beliefs are yeah
yeah that's crazy I mean it's Arizona though
I live there for 3 years so you know I live
in Tucson I love Tucson I love it I would
love to go back my wife would never ever
ever move there now micro and she ate it but
I would I would I loved it I love you son
great weather
ssst believe it or not it's not hot in
Tucson it's not hot in the winter it's not
hot at all it's actually freezing
wrestlers are basketball team
so am I fancy phone calls before
yeah it just doesn't it
Pascal beers which is like yeah that's
pretty high to silence those up on the
mountains every time every time there's a
ski resort up there yeah the nouns in Tucson
Tucson Tucson Tucson is like one of the
number one Observatory stuff they have
statutes in the city that prevents light
pollution because it's use for astronomy
it's absolutely beautiful I miss it so bad I
do I miss big Open Spaces I love North
Carolina to but I really miss the big Open
Spaces of the Arizona I was back when I had
my motorcycle to so I would just go on big
rides
yeah
be down in a bit I just love that the whole
town is like dark even at night you know
like when you're the street lights are all
caps they have they can't have any license
beat that goes up
your little fantasy football investment
instruments cool
what is pom College phosphate for colleges
practice makes perfect
famous artists one of the hackers and
connect computer systems
I'm going to bring a college is very nice
and stares and models for each model
students go through and she has her flying
press watch a pre-recorded module lectures
on YouTube it says they call it flipped
education
Dropbox Chrysler Pacifica Paso station
attend wine glasses on Twitch
what I've never seen him
I've never seen him how have I not seen
these guys I got to go see this
maybe I have seen him
white belt to blue belt
this week at one point I followed I am
following them why am I never seen them on
because their last update was the plane was
last year that's why
yeah the last thing I did was last year
I mean that's why I'm following them
actually
when the organizer.com wow uncollege yeah
home College apparently it's a thing
I got a new to tell me a sandwich from that
point on a dojo this is what I'm going to
build a steel sack I've been I've been
starting that I had a we had we had a the
same course worth kind of game that you
would play when you play Shenzhen except for
you know you unlock this and that it's like
a narrative and I was a big Dungeons &
Dragons dungeon Master's back in the day I
really
the day I really I want this is one of my
long-term goals and I do I have too many
other things to do but one of my long-term
goals is to write a
a narrative a really long narrative that
takes you through everything that you would
have to learn for Linux know the basics of
the Boost and some of the stuff for
cybersecurity I think it would be so fun to
ask me about track me and hack the box I
love them great yeah it doesn't know
I've already done videos series of videos on
this every year I do so I can go watch the
last ones if you want I'm actually in the
middle of a kind of organizing that right
now
and if it's a go to the challenge problems
they do have challenged Base education or
discovered Discovery in Adele's rolling Base
education would call it the problem with
challenge Base education is it it's it's
often not repeatable so people will do
enough they'll like hackerbox right and they
won't remember how they did it
unless somebody like comes back around and
says hey I'm going to speed run this and do
it at like 10 times they don't solidify the
learning because they don't you know
brother say yes I don't use it. Not a fan
I'm not a fan of right I say she tried to
say she was just it's just the Chrome Under
the Hood
yeah it's it's not attached browser
it's not it's it you can't even use it
without a Firefox installed so I'm not a fan
yeah I don't I don't I don't I don't use
graphic roses. I think they're I do when I
need to do graphics and then I'll open it up
for you yeah
it doesn't the thing that the frog has so
this is the problem with with the fun
challenge Base education is I think it
leaves gaps
you can call it failure base to
challenge-based a deliverable bass when
they're going to call you know you get the
thing
oh I did a whole video on that if
set my the short answer on text browsing
in case you're wondering is my
recommendation anybody wants to text me
browsing right you want to take space
browsing start with W 3 m
start with W 3M cuz it's easy it works out
of the gate and it has been bindings and
then move up to links and configure the
Linksys virtually impossible to use out of
the box you have to customize the shit out
of it but I still prefer because I like the
formatting better like this for example
white space on the side that it does not do
that I want to be sure and does not do that
you can text me for us is a big part of of
the Boost as well as to contact that I need
to cover the Boost so that's kind of what
I'm doing right now is I'm kind of thinking
about what needs to go in there
let us go back to that thank you for tell me
about poem poem College I did not know that
was a thing
yeah I just checked it's going to suffer
from some of the same problems that academic
learning does
I don't know that but we'll figure it out
and what else we got we can do
I want to look at the ocean all stuff again
we got to get this in so I'm I'm struggling
right now because
I've been doing these Labs I have a ton of
labs right
do I have a ton of labs and I have been
using
I have been using the notion of the lab as
it get repo
I did four years Academia Nick knows all of
this for years I used a month for emails to
my texts I don't use anymore most of my
email
what's my email ID on my phone
why don't you seem all that much at all how
much all of my email ID on my phone and text
makes browsing on your phone doesn't make
any sense because I don't send email
I don't use email. Hezekiah so
yeah thank you so much is it what I want to
just mention here is that
so this is a technique I've been falling for
a long time then I'm trying to codify it for
others when when I'm going to go on an
educational Adventure which is something
that people should know how to do but I
think of calling University versus old
learning from work that's exactly what we're
talking about right now actually just wrote
a wrote something about that I mean
they are red, then yeah there's some that's
some something I just wrote about that yet
the bottom line is
I feel like
there's no structure around explorative
learning you know Adventure type of money I
kind of knew what I found myself doing and
I've observed others doing is Dale
no sent out a challenge and started with a
too big of a challenge like I'm going to
make a Discord bot or I am going to hack
this website I'm going to do this and or I'm
going to learn to read that he's right and
it had to break it down and in the process
of breaking it down each year they sit down
you sit down and have a session right like
okay what am I going to do in this session
when am I going to try to do so since today
if you can go back and watch my bod it was
like how do I use an FS how do I set up an
fs and never file system honest and you know
how do I do it and how do I do it anyway
that's not going to blow up my my computer
the world or my job in the employer and so
it's going to set the parameters around what
do I want to get out of this
and every time I thought about that I
believe it it comes back to how do you
document that and it's the best way of
documenting is to me is to document the
results and this is the same way work
happens so
you know your your employer gives you a task
a challenge and that thing is broken down
into a bunch of other tests and challenges
some of which are very generic and you
should be able to do any time and a lot of
those also take the place of take a form of
recipes inside of books so Riley got very
famous off of making recipe books because
what the recipes Allrecipes are our document
the other like that like modular
documentation of how to accomplish the task
that's what a recipe book is if you go look
at any of your other books
books from O'Reilly
write a cookbook store called her
so you got the python cookbook you know how
do I open a file in it how do I you know
censuses
I think you're hard in practice it's the
sign that you don't your theory is weak yeah
I think yeah I think it did they complement
each other but I think so for example I have
zero information about how to do it is
torture scenes and things I've never needed
any form of your sides and then I wanted to
write my own pain. I mean my own markdown
Purser and so I went through that the high
school and tan dog and I studied at all and
I actually mean I had an immediate practical
need to understand rooted no trees which are
covered you're very theoretical thing that
are covered in another big freaking in a
book The Textbook that if I paid like 80
bucks for it but they're in there and I went
in there and I understood why there are
there or how to Traverse a notary all these
questions that were very theoretical
questions then I was said they were really
practice because I needed to be able to
understand how to how to park, Mark and and
so the Practical kind of led to the
theoretical and
I can get dive in and I understood the why I
am in a cared about the Y more than being
told about the Y without having any you know
practical application for
application for a net I feel like the
balances is essential the fact that these
cookbooks have just you know got to remember
this is an old one
the fact that these cookbooks are there
just as a tribute to the fact that we look
for practical ideas like you do these things
to get this results right and we can look
them up and we can like repeat those things
is it it really much is like I miss everyone
so so
what is etiquette for what we're doing right
now Iowa Supreme Court
I just have chili and we just have chili
today
yeah practical does make you fall in love
with Terry because they're like if I
understand this better than I'll be able to
do this better actually it was when I was
looking at recorded just sent person I fell
in love with the theory of of parsing out
rhythms and I was like oh my God this makes
my life so much easier but it wasn't until
then that I cared so I feel like there needs
to be more of an emphasis on that not too
much you can have too much of one of the
other right so if you have if you have a
code here like a like I don't know I can't
code academy or freecodecamp going on people
finish the challenge and they don't ever
seek to understand it or they don't slow
down they just know they're off to the next
challenge in the way to get the piece of
paper in the award in the achievement at the
end so they're itchy mature than they really
don't care about the learning along the way
are they are if they do they like this whole
system is designed to get Addie emphasize
the value of the learning and overemphasize
the achievement they're going to get out of
it and to me that's why we actually had
somebody say that who is
a cyber security engineer for the government
in this chat they might be there now and
they say why are you why are you taking so
much time doing this this way why don't you
just do it and move on and I said because I
want understand it they said will you never
you don't have time for that on the job you
just have to get the solution to get it out
I don't like this isn't the job I want to
understand and then and it slows me down
obviously but I feel like that kind of
education is the way to go so I'll bring it
back home here
what I'm trying to do is the whole idea
behind the credentials is
I don't take to facilitate it's like create
opportunities for people to do the
exploration that's a practical system
employable skills focuses on tach eliminates
broken ocean teachers
is also a person a form letter without
formal education but I also don't know if I
have a degree would damage my career no
longer I don't think it would have been
careers you know certain things requiring
right
I can replace the teacher with mentors so
these are already written a lot about this
and it's coming back up because I just
finished
a lab McCall it right Mike when I say I
finish the lab what I mean by a lab is a is
a you know a certain amount of time where I
have been getting my hands dirty fulfilling
the requirements that I set for myself if to
make a thing or two accomplish a task and
and I set forth to do it and then I go out
and I'm messy and I searched and I find out
how to do it and then you guys helped me and
at the end of it all we have to do this like
tons and tons of notes we have a few things
that work and if some scrubs here we have a
lot of artifacts I made a lot of stuff that
comes out of that morning and all of that
stuff goes into a hog I need to talk to you
soon so all that stuff currently is getting
thrown into these labs
right now and I like that I like the idea of
the lab being the place where you put all of
than Messi artifacts it's like a lighter
clippings and everything is like if you're
going to pull the file folder out you know
this got all of this shit you did to learn a
specific thing and but and there's really no
some of these Labs a really huge and some
are small some of the labs and the reason I
put lime instead of Challenge and I really
really really really glad that we've changed
for this because some of these labs and in
order and catastrophic failure so that's
what's the weather like all my God this was
so stupid the fact that I even tried to do
this here's the conclusion it doesn't work
this way
work this way. All of the evidence that this
failed miserably I know all written here in
his big messy blob that I can go back and
look at and then maybe something else will
find that and I actually haven't asked
myself do I need to leave all these failures
out here you know I fix an apple is sending
it manifesting kind is like fucking
disastrously bad idea
you know and you know why would you do it
can you do it probably should you do it
probably not
I don't know if you can actually makes me
want to go test I want again cuz now I know
how to do an effect on a virtual machine who
makes me want to look at it cuz I know and
if that's better now so how do we capture
all of this stuff in an organized way in a
way so that we can go back and find it and
the way that we can share it with others and
more support Lee in a way that we can
demonstrate that we have learned something
by producing artifacts which are proof of
Triumph proof of work that can be used to
establish trust whether it's with an
employer and educator or yourself so you
have all of those things took the point I'm
trying to make is I'm I'm struggling
cuz I feel like
Ben Kaiser on registry I don't know I don't
know what this looks like all right this is
we're just we're just out here just talking
to you know just talking randomly so
my gut feel right now is it a lab should
still be the place
to put all of our experimentation stuff but
here's the downside the downside of this is
that if you break out all of these led Vibes
in this way they become disconnected from my
cell casting notes so
recently
let me give you an example of that when was
the last time we did the communities one I
put all of these references and I put all of
this solutions after lapping I think
patroclus I think you're onto the right
thing yeah
so it should be required to have any
companies that that's what I think okay so I
know live streaming separate I agree
I think I agree completely with her and I
don't even know if we need to name it loud I
think we should maybe
that mean this is the whole thing or we have
the overlap between the ocms requirements
and I am a badge and a lab
and we need to talk about that it's possible
we can have both so didn't realize we're
sorry it's just called the main male what
we're doing right now we're trying to figure
out what two things are called and what's
her cardinality how many of them are there
so yeah I know know know I would never do
that so the first the first lesson learned
here from the latest Labs that we've done is
that I don't want anything that I can't
query in my Celica. I don't want any of the
notes me the whole point the whole point of
it it's like it's like me making a different
notebook for every fucking Labrador doing
and having a search through Mall can do it
so so that the modification to the way I'm
going to go do things going forward is
pretty simple
all of the note taking all of the stuff like
that it's going to probably I'm going to
move it to his little
now that the problem with moving into is
that all is that
it's going to be in this big mess in place
but that means a source going to be easy to
be found the note says put this way the
notes write the notes and the artifacts and
things like that then minor artifacts can go
my solution is stuff can go in my own
notebook in my house I will cast and then I
confided
no sometimes the lab includes like a
finished product like for example if you can
make a Discord bot right so there you have a
deliverable you get up with a thing in this
actually goes in your you're getting a repo
that shows you know shit in your do really
well and it exists it's not just some lab
experiment is actually a thing that you can
use and that's up to me is the ultimate goal
the ultimate goal is to help people make
real stuff that matters but that in their
GitHub and take all the slab should put it
take it out I bottom line I'm going to be
moving the lab stuff out of my get
if might get repo because it's cluttering it
right now and I'm going to be putting it in
my cell cast and instead and then that will
pull up when I'm searching for something
that the other thing about that too is that
right now I can't give people stuff so like
right now I can do that chat and I can give
them everything that I've done about
kubernetes right or is that all right
there's all that stuff about simulcasting
and I can send that to everybody I can't do
that right now with my lab content because
it's not in my soul casting it's not in my
second brain it's not loaded up and so my
second ride so I can have a third brain you
don't have to go pull that in and I I'm
going to get rid of that
what's up I said is he in the house is going
to be in
add this much fun with a text access Kelly
nice
oh my God yeah it really pays crazy crazy
good money yes it does it's really fun. Some
really phenomenal language to learn and
likes her or like yeah I wish I could learn
to like Sterling and get paid money for that
I probably should
is your example and go look at your example
ask you look at that
SMS library history yep the Russian circus
super cool it's a super cool
is there a series or is this it the write-up
of of requirements I think it's a really
important thing
but I don't know that that is that a lab
thing or is that an ocms thing
I feel like I feel like there's overlap yeah
yeah I do I feel like there
I feel I feel like there's there's overlap
and that's that's what I'm trying to get my
head around
you know so if
I mean we all just keep thinking about this
for a second because
so I have a couple goals I was going to set
forth
framers for exploration center requirements
for product right yeah
Atlantis like hey here's your project will
go play it's like that's by Montessori does
that by the way so Montessori does that they
have these learning experiments Labs model
whatever and then there's parameters and do
this and reminds me of the modules shop and
mechanics when I was in school in school
that there's a there was a lab a mechanical
lab called module shop and had about 70
modules in it and each module was a project
and you got something out of it when you
went to him you would go there and one of
them you made like a buffalo head you know
nickel ring and another one uses
electrolytes there's another with a grinder
and it had literally the steps to do to do
it and you got to Tinker with everything and
play around with it and you got you know to
get some stuff out of it at the same time
was there a formal listing of all the
requirements you fulfilled in order to do it
no and by the end it was nothing formally
that said hey here look at all the things
you just learned how to do it's kind of like
I feel like the labs are like I feel like
there's if I were visualizing this and I
feel like there's
there's like a formal list of things by
tasks that you need to know skills right and
that's that's like a massive thing that's
organized by however we categorize them into
badges or whatever and then you have
all the labs and in the labs the feel so you
would see you like this lab to Phil's these
10 things over here you know all over right
they could be like spread all over across
the list of things you need to do
a list of things you need to do but the lab
gives you opportunities to fill things that
are on the list and to practice doing them
and stuff and then you can go back and say
okay what things did I have to fill on the
list
yeah that's what I'm saying and that's the
badges I'll come so soon system the
awesomest stuff is the badges know when I'm
also learning here to is that we can
actually jump in and let the Practical stuff
Drive the creation of the list and that's
what we talked about last time you never
last time we talked about doing that
focusing on the projects and less on the
theory so so for example this NFS project I
just did I can go back and I can review the
project than I can say okay what were if I
was writing a job description about the
things that I just filled by doing this and
learning about it what how it would look
like and I can actually say Okay line item
latam latam latam I can find like 5 10 15
line items of tasks that I can now for Phil
because I did this lab and then we can take
those and we decide okay where did it go did
they go in their own badge maybe so maybe
they're split across three bad just maybe we
don't know they just go into this big pile
of tasks that you can accomplish that are
are unique and that is the database that we
need in fact I think I think the more I get
into this the more I I think that we don't
really need to have a task in a category but
what we need is a massive database of tasks
and that would be a recipe book or our task
registry so that when someone goes to so so
this is something you can't do right now
right if they like you sell those cookbooks
they have right the one thing that there are
missing it so you can't search them right so
people people what do you do if your job
gives you a problem editor they give you a
job listing is kind of thing you need to do
right so it says it very specific terms
here's with the tasks you need to do and you
like okay let me go search and you searched
how do I do this test can you find 10 20
hits on the internet you go to research it
and you do those things you create a little
experimental thing blah blah Van Buren when
you called that are not and you practice it
and then you finished it and now you've
fulfilled that test now you know how to do
it but we don't have right now is a
centralized way to search for
all the tasks that you could potentially be
asked to do in the tech world at least the
ones that we cover so what I'm getting at is
the awesomest system even though I still
like the idea of badges badges are basically
a groupings let's say you're going to get a
vagrant badge right you get a vagrant bad
will if you're going to get a vagrant badge
that means you need to do you know these 56
eat ass and you need to be able to prove
that you can do those tasks right I think to
about this is that nor granular the tasks
and there's new at this is frustrating
because there are other systems like this
that exist in HR I remember at IBM we have
to go through this evaluation thing and we
would spend hours on this thing just
checking boxes but all the tasks that were
relevant to our job we just click good cook
box box box box you know and it was really
tedious and annoying and and it didn't we
didn't really understand the practical
application of it right but
if I could have like clicked on one of those
things and it could have said okay now open
up all of the registered Labs or work that
people have done to accomplish that task and
I could have looked at it that way or I
could have gone back and forth and I could
have said okay you know this lab this thing
you get to directions to come out this right
if you in this is why I did it still so I
can still see the primary goal is still
subject of the young people was to
experiment it was to try a lots of different
things can we do web development game
development hacking Minecraft servers
welding you know say soldering we're going
to do yoga everything and it was an ability
to explore a bunch of things and that's kind
of what this kind of program as well so they
would explore all of these different
projects and say who I want to do that a
badger I want to do this thing right and
then and then they would and they would like
it
so then the next phase is okay with what
other
you know Labs have this thing and so if if
they could have gone to I think it had taken
that lab that they just did order that that
project whatever and said here are the
things that are line items on and then they
can they could look up in a centralized
database of those same things and say well
what other things have
other things have this cuz I really like it.
Only cuz they find other lab project that we
related to it but we can start organizing
things like careers that contain those
things in them and I mean we can say we
could create job titles and responsibilities
and things like that there is so sated with
the task and they're all listed in the same
you know job listing sort of way and I liked
was imperative verb in the beginning like
you to maintain bubble bubble and and now
they can actually explore and kind that
module shop way and at the same time they
can see other stuff that's related to that
stuff they might have missed another lab is
not covered in that lab and then they could
they could also see another list it says and
by the way here are the jobs that are
related to the stuff that you tend to be
liking here here's here the job descriptions
here's information about the stuff that you
are discovering through practical expiration
goes with what you doing
yeah anytime environments to facilitate the
lab McGregor absolutely and then we have
containers and stuff that go with the lamb
and not to mention assessment now right so
now you have you have easier ways to assess
because he's Sussman is based on a lab and
you say okay if you the reverse right so if
you want to check to see whether somebody
matches a job so let's say you have your
database of job titles over here and then
you have that tied to you know the some sort
of compositive of the tasks they need to be
able to do and then you say okay in
assessment for this person based on those
tests and then you say OK Google show me all
the labs that have those tests in them and
you go grab like 10 20 labs and you say OK
Google to do these three labs within 35
minutes
so now you have the method of assessing
people including yourself to see if you
would fit that job or you can have people
searching the job categories you have no
fucking idea what is involved in those jobs
they just have heard about it and then they
could associate the tasks that go with the
job and then they can see if I can sample
the labs and stuff that go with that in the
day of the life of an asari or something
like that so you can people coming at it
from the career side you can't people just
exploring from the other side and there's
like the central listing of of of tasks and
skills and and and that's the ultimate
impractical attacked one of the hardest
parts about practical application like this
is that you have to you have the word the
stuff that goes into the test database as a
task and that's a little tough because you
know the central people in a to do a job you
have to do you have to have skills I still
am I to meet to me is you
you need to perform a task that I'm 60 words
a minute that is a skill some people would
call it an ability and ability is a
different thing and then knowledge right so
now it's just straight-up theoretical
knowledge you know raw understanding of
knowledge that informs your task in your
skills but but bike and I know he would have
Phillips head screwdriver know what the word
Phillips means right so knowledge includes
terminology sassy must be able to perform
the tasks got it
yeah sort of but there's not just that
there's there's stuff like you need to be
able to grok certain terms right it's so in
enlisting when it when you start to break
this stuff down it gets confusing because
then you're like okay do you know what SQL
is right can you tell me what ask you all
the knowledge part of all of this is is
essential but it's kind of like the
information you need to know in order to
accomplish a task right and that's harder to
listen to Central database because you end
up using and abusing the same you know
understand or gerak or something like I see
that I see you super grok grok means grok
SQL know it is in a Crock-Pot original trees
bloom in so basically your theory was
captured as a task
right so it didn't understand rooted no
trees if you don't know who the no trees are
not going to go to fucking do this make sure
you understand. No trees now let's make a
rooted notary you know is it because you
can't you can't this kind of system can be
completely and tiling products practical
it's got to have you have to have stirred
their dependencies to some of the practical
skills on the knowledge you can't even do it
without understanding it so there is so so
how does it get listed right and that's
where
that's where things get interesting
I bet you the day off I think I think of a
comeback to how would it show up on a job on
a job if we keep asking yourself how would
they show up on a job posting it's called oh
my God crush-crush-crush desire I did not
know that that's crazy it's fucking crazy so
I mean let's list I've been let's do one and
just see what happens
the more I get into the so the more I think
that we need to keep everything flat
we need to keep things flat if we if we try
to get into conversation with you trouble if
we keep things flat and then we allowed
tagging I think that that's going to be a
safer bet
so let's see what that would even mean
so so like let's let's take the last one we
just did let's do the NFS vagrant right
I mean I ended up with a bigger file okay
cool right
and I don't see it this I think that all of
this could go into
I don't know I mean
I think I think this could go in his that'll
I think the
the deliverable from this tastes labels and
annotations I agree that's what I'm saying
yes that's the way to to make something yeah
absolutely
I mean literally cross head screwdriver in
English really well that's super cool that's
cool I did not know that I think that the
end result of this particular should be a
published vagrants Cloud entry and that the
rest of these notes should go there they
should become
tonight then I wonder cuz is it a project or
not right that is a I do sore think it is a
project
but I don't think I would call the lab at
that point I think it should be called
something else you know this isn't this
isn't no longer allow this is this isn't
this is a product that that I don't want to
have lab in the name I want to change this
to say hey is that okay so if somebody
hopped it at somebody came across this
vagrant file I would want them to judge you
based on its Merit not not based on the fact
that it's a lab write it's not allowed
anymore it's a it's a thing it's an artifact
it's a it's a vagrant configuration file for
you know a specific number to set up with an
fs and I could document that way I can
document it as a project I do too I think a
project has been for one of our Labs yeah
and if that slap was make it loud because
I'm can race track exactly and so when I'm
trying to get at is I don't even those these
were labs they started out as an exploration
they became things and they stopped being
Labs at this point this is no longer allowed
this is this is the thing this is a thing I
can use and Sharon other people can use
Adventures yeah and I like that too I mean
there's I mean at this point it's just a
finished product I don't really don't even
have to have a word for it in terms of like
this if it come back and we say okay well
what did we do here what were the skills
acquired right and how would we even less
those skills
you know we could just I mean it's the
skills we could just goes like yeah more
time to hear something is largely listed
here create 3 vagrant virtual machines using
a i k so this is the difference between a
credential and a project write a project
says something very specific it's like a
recipe a project is more like a recipe it's
like you know beat three eggs and then add
them to your sauce right now you're learning
how to freaking see your something else
right there's some other thing you're
learning their butt
the example of
example of doing that task is very specific
and this particular case right so create
three Bacon Breakfast easy versabox disable
swap on the machine and this is the kind of
thing that you would put on a test I mean if
you were going to ever touch yourself or
somebody else who'd say here here's the task
this is the task go do it and to do that
task you're going to have to use a certain
skills right and what are the certain set of
skills then you're going to use right and
different a task is different to me and if
Yu-Gi-Oh Mel. Going to send it to me that
task is the Fulfillment of a skill a task is
the execution of a skill so you have a skill
and then you have an execution of that skill
and that equals attask and obviously certain
tasks required execution of several skills
in order that you can break down any task
into the execution of a finite set of skills
and figuring
what they call those skills and how to list
them and how to be able to look them up is
is the essential part of the skills stack
database that's what we need we need a
database of skills
and see how we need we need to figure that
part out
so that that's the stuff right so
if I'm going to put skills her what would I
put I would put yeah
free database what is this
as I can I store
a metaphor
well I mean I don't know this is this is
this get the cave
what we need to do is talk about the things
a little bit more so
I miss you find my
we need to do a bit or do they not only
because I
actually
yeah
there is one that I don't go delivery drone
education
so this stuff is kind of coming back up into
my mind
in fact I'm really glad that I saved this
this tutorial is actually a lab I think
and I really really really want to have
project and exercise so both of these are
both an exercise and a project or require
the use of skills
but an exercise is repeatable it's it's it's
helps you memorize things as specific as a
project takes a bit more time you could
repeat the whole project but it's it's not
design help you memorize you know specific
skills it's it's more designed to help you
combine a bunch of skills together into
something useful so you can get a
deliverable right but if you can complete
the exercise of usually like 1 to 1 like you
have several exercises for a specific skill
and you can do those things really quickly
and they're designed to like solidify the
knowledge so for example you know creating
an each section in Ruby right that would be
something that you could do to get write in
different ways so you have the like the
repeatable stuff and then you have the
Project based stuff and if I had one
criticism of a free code camp and things
like that they focused too much on the
project on the challenge and stuff and not
enough on the repeat
thanks so we had to give an example I had
how to spell yeah exercises are totally in
the morning yeah they're based there they
have
our base there they have their silly either
small there fast checked me you can call me
projects we used to call him to Montague
many projects because they're tiny there
their they're really exercises right they're
designed to improve your your strength in
your ability to do something in your skill
and whereas the project is like you know
that the project is the sculpture write the
exercise is whittling on a piece of the
project is you know an ornament that you
ordered from it and solder together an order
you know and design it from to have been
rescued from China and Kim are going to the
exercise is learning just getting a
soldering Board of soldering 15 times in a
row right so there's there's exercises and
there's projects and I think that the
projects are
where the lab comes in now a lab the project
says this is a specification in fact I kind
of feel like this project should be called
lab instead and the tutorial is a tutorial
is you walking through the creation of that
project step by step as the solution or
Implement ation of that lap here's here's
how we in fact I think if we change the word
project to lab I think we'll get it because
project I mean it is Project though you know
I mean I think any collab is a better word
because what is the lab Lab is a project
with the goal of learning right so a project
is is it is it allowed is the Lamb is a
project with a goal of learning as opposed
to is it to them is probably bigger than a
lot of room here to put project and or lab
alive is kind of a combination of skills
that maybe don't have something that turns
out to be a deliverable
it might and it might not just this diagram
probably needs to change the lit yeah but
this this is the reason I'm going through
this is because this is this is where your
curriculum comes from write your curriculum
is built off of this stuff and if you don't
know what do you think he was Alyssa
tutorial tutorial is just a just a guided
project really it's all it is is somebody
stepping you through the project and that's
one way to learn is probably not the best
way if you do a tutorial and everybody knows
it so you do tutorial hell and you too you
don't learn anything you go through the
tutorial you do what they say you don't know
anything because you haven't done any
repeatable exercises you haven't done any
original thinking with the creation of the
lab because you just watch this is going on.
They said
that doesn't challenge you at all if it
doesn't it doesn't get you to do the
learning it doesn't get you to do any
research and so that's why people say that
there are in 240 Health ex is not even call
this is real before I used to call it a LED
project or write my favorite word for this
is a work through write a work through a
work through is hey we're going to work
through this lab or this project together
and as we work through it you're going to do
the work first and then I'm going to do the
work and you're going to be in Pacifica to
be on you doing the work at figuring it out
and then looking at the solution that I've
done and comparing your work so that you can
enter the virtual way pair program with me
while I'm doing it and if you just if you
just you know do the tutorial and don't do
anything else you can learn anything
cuz you haven't you haven't taken any of it
you know you haven't taken any variation on
it so I still think this model holds up and
I think this is the reason I wanted this is
because what do we build a database of right
I think the database is we have to build the
database of a skills it has it the database
has to be skills we have to figure out what
are the skills that are that are happening
and I have another take on this someplace
where it says its tasks ribbon
yes a boy
no I just acted like a better one
a database for each yeah
I see open where is it
she can curriculum classes
thanks for slightly different yeah this one
is education as a service
I totally forgot about this I forgot about
this I'm so happy I found this one oh my God
I spend so much time on this
yeah
yes oh my God I'm so glad I found this you
have no idea how glad I am I found this I I
spent I spent a month on this coming up with
all this stuff
analysis uml little bit of his chances I
think so so this is
since I go to the gym on education as a
service
Ellie Ray custom down again so that
Mentor guides and knows the project and
courses are composing projects
they're Aggregates of that and then you have
an instructor who kind of need something
yeah add end of this is important part of
skill
has an exercise to go with it I don't this
is I don't know if I still wanted to keep
that part this was how I was trying to break
down the actual content we have the
assessment of the top X scale is a topic
yeah this is this was me trying to create
curriculum that actually went into something
so
yeah there's there's other topics that have
stuffed peppers go off requires another yams
us compose
as soon as a folio of Chima said it one of
March events in a portfolio of certification
and a stack of skills as of this is their
stack their skill stack would be hey here's
all the skills they learn so miss asig Mi
Mexico
Education Services yeah
I mean the reason this is written this way
is because the database for any given
students or person in here would be I hears
was the main thing was it was in my skill
Sac so like if you if you've done these
certain number of labs are project or
something like that I want to be able to
pull up every skill that you supposedly have
by having finished it and then I can
randomize
stuff from that I can say
you know and it's this actually keeps
education very flexible because it's like
you can play around with different labs and
stuff and you can start to see what you're
going to do and then you can dynamically
pull out a assessments for yourself over for
the teacher or whatever and you can pull
them out an end show was supposedly is in
their skills that and the skill stack is is
just a big fucking list of all the skills
they have
and and that's that's where this goes and
then you could like deprecate certain skills
and other things like that so what goes into
a skill
you know that's that's a different question
I want to go back to my other one in for a
second then delete it and God dammit
skill stack yeah I did yes I did
just for fun I deliberately did that that's
a nod to the old school days
it was it was it was also the gate that you
need to name it was to get a unique the main
name it was kind of a nod to old-school Unix
days I have is there a h many things but
that's working
I am I knew that affected since then by the
way there's been other corporations start
that are called skill Sac s k i l s e t s a
c k I knew I was going to have to explain it
to people how to drive how to write it all
this time and
Simon and it was annoying
Model T S Play the song One
and
yeah I was just out of all that you know
what the hell
all right so this is just a different thing
this was this was a pseudocode about how how
learning happened and I had teaching here
even though I don't like teach SI products
for coarse Rich Project of course he's
Friday teach my students to clarify what I
am trying to go deliver the car cheapest
associate project free stuff you can project
the topic is new but a success Mastery of
love you 7% total Faith discuss off back to
the top of your skill demonstrated find
skill
at this is I use the word teacher and some
purpose for a different meaning cuz that was
that post was in my my room and sometimes I
would describe loyal to two parents what you
know what what is it that we do
and and that's enough that's not always
obvious
where's my other one I can't find it now
condemn it
oh deliverer deliverer will drive in
education right there's delivery and deliver
Bowl
there that's a mistake by the way yeah yeah
this is a this is an old one
it's the same thing though f
that's what I don't know
so there was no concept of telecast and no
taking anywhere near this before the closest
thing I had was something called the code
book where you know kids and people would
maintain their own code book which is the
richest like a messy scratch pad for them to
try out all the different coding and stuff
but there wasn't there was nothing that can
to what we're doing now and there was no
notion of containers and stuff like that
which I think we need so
I think I think the important thing we need
to focus on is is you know what are the list
of skills and how do we capture the work
I think we need to put some structure around
a few things one of them is these projects
right so the labs are projects whatever you
want to call him
and I feel like we need to do this diagram
better
sometimes the deliverable is a failed lab
and I mean I I feel like a project is like
needs to be guaranteed that is going to have
a deliverable that works because it's been
tested whereas a lab
might be a total disaster and ended results
the end result being you don't get anything
out of it and you just learned a ton
you know and I think I think I think Labs
should be
maybe we don't formalize a bit maybe that's
the way that people capture their learning
as a sub segment of whatever their code book
used to be before it's like I'm going to go
a lab is a an informal structure around your
you're you know exploration of something and
and in the project is if it's a different
thing the project was like okay where to go
from X and Y and we're going to exercise the
skills that we know exists and if you need
help we have a tutorial over here it'll take
you through it I mean like riding a Discord
bot so I project something you could
document really well you can you can put it
in a book and and and that would be you know
if something like like a Discord bot or web
server or somewhere that has exercises are
these your people things again also very
solid right things that are that are able to
tations of us her number because I think
we're missing a piece in this here and
that's the lab what happens when you don't
have a
happens when you don't have a project right
now so labs labs lead to projects because
you're like you like you're running into the
walls or just signing this doesn't work just
doesn't work just as all your Rica this
totally works let's make this into a project
that we can make a YouTube video about and
we can document right I would never make a
YouTube video about me failing to use NFS
and kind
I don't know how much how about you though
that would be but you know somebody wanted
to see what why what happened did you ever
experiment with this and try to do this in
this way and learn the family oh my God yes
I totally failed if you want to go see my
failures over here and look at this you know
or you're right it up in your nose I I think
that lives should not have their own repost
I'm starting to get to the point and that's
with the started this all started because
I'm getting too many loud Repose I'm like
this is like coloring up my get repo it's
it's making my profile and get him a lame I
don't like that right so so a lab either
results in a finished polished project that
is the you know the the the product of all
the learning that went into the lab that it
can stand on its own Merit and prove that
you know a certain number of skills but
nobody would do that looking at it they
would just say oh my God he made this really
cool thing right
and then we have with the messy lab and no
taking stuff that's all very messy and if
there's one thing zettelkasten is Miss Messi
write the messy note taking and stuff like
that should go in to your ears on a cast
that and that if there are a couple
artifacts there those artifacts are probably
not going to
you know impact yours all casting to much so
for example if you had some other reason I
wouldn't want to put into my soul casting
and the reason I want to put my failures and
when I search for something I want to find
all the I got I tried that I don't want to
do it again I remember now see him say it
you want that to show up you want that the
search you want those searches to hit
we need to ensure that we don't run into you
should get I quit having to get have a
meeting past a thousand years has rejected
yet we know that we're going to exceed the
ability for get to store everything and you
know we have that issue would like large
large files as I can
I think it's Emma Cason should just be no
sin frankly a lab is mostly no taking
you know what I mean I feel like a lab is
mostly note-taking
but I don't know I don't know
I feel like it is I feel like it's mostly no
taking you know
I just don't know I don't know what would
move in do with aluminum do a lot of this
because he was just writing you would have a
lot of psychological mind experiments you
know but he wouldn't he he wouldn't have a
lot of artifacts from his exploration hey
doctor
Aaron s he wouldn't have
my wife's Yanni so you know I'm I'm
wondering about that
in the technical world in the digital
technical world
cloning excetera right
what's what's what's this exit the technical
world for a while that's what if we apply
these methods to an education that does not
uniquely have digital assets so
if you were going to do this for like
welding or something how would you do that
and what is the what is the equivalent give
example so let's say soldering right
how what is an exercise that would help your
skill to solder be able to solder and he's a
very real skills these are things that we
need it makes me let's look at some of the
physical world little bit more
in the physical world if you said I needed
to solder are you going to answer I don't
know how
solder two wires going to be alright
or else but I'd lab a lab I guess it's kind
of stretch to say that but a lab would be
use one of these solder boards so that I
want to get when actually they have these
these boards that are just designed for you
to practice your soldering and you can run a
current through them and what if your
soldered connection is worth while ago on or
something so the whole point of the board is
it is a throwaway boards are like really
cheap and they're there to help people like
me you know actually get good with soldering
and
you know where would that fit in here where
would that fit in here what would that
activity be I believe it would be an
exercise right it would be an exercise that
has a dependency on something in the
physical world obviously where would you
right about that what are some of the
artifacts are going to be discarded what
would you would you hold onto your solder
board after you finish practicing it would
you throw it away you probably throw it away
you might you might keep it for for you know
Old Times Sake but and I believe that
there's a parallel to that in the digital
form so like you know your notes eaters no
notes there or anything but if you if you
did happen to have no so I can say if you
took a note and said remember to hold my
hand like this are you are you took a
picture of your hands in the right position
or you know you you had a little little tips
and tricks right those things would go into
your notebook they are going to your
notebook they would be something to help you
remember at
go back to that right with the chances of
you holding on to that so I can practice on
her board a pretty low you throw it away and
you wouldn't care if I put hang it on your
wall cuz you're pregnant you're proud of it
or something but it's not something you
would use to demonstrate your skill you
would just you would just throw it out and
that's what I feel like I have to do with
most of these labs in my get a repo and I
get a reply I feel like most of the labs
I've done the conclusions I have made and
the notes that I've acquired are far more
important Fortin than the failed artifacts
that are left around there the equivalent to
my burned solder board right and they can be
discarded I don't think I need him I think
the important thing is to capture the
learning in a retrievable way in the saddle
cast in which is the primary way of
retrieving anyting so
but that would mean keeping large-scale
artifacts out of the okay so we we keep
nothing but but we already have in there you
know an occasional Imogen mostly text notes
in description and and then you can pull it
up anytime is a good thing about that is so
let's say let's say for example complain
about how I'm doing so far so right now I
have this phenomenally awesome they can file
right this is the exact vagrant file that I
need to do most of the staging for anything
else
but how do I find it
this maker and file is not in any of my
secondary recall it's not in my Zello
castanets nowhere so unless I put all of my
notes related to this someplace else but
even better is I need to put this code
what's the product of this lab is finished I
need to put this code this recipe into his
metal
it needs to go into a tunnel and then when
I'm searching when I'm when I'm working
Sunday and I need that thing again I just
goes It goes at finding I go find this exact
go copy and paste it boom I'm done even even
more so I might even put it in my Snippets
collection should say so at that point at
that point this is actually a liability or
is it works against me having it being his
soul lab someplace else cuz I have no
fucking way of finding it
give me give me three weeks and there's no
way I'll be able to find it
so so they can sue in this case that
artifact of that knowledge needs that
template needs to come out of there and it
needs to go in something that's consumable
where is repetition and replication for
scales to become second nature absolutely
yeah
we have to build your own reputation into
stuff yeah that this is structured way in a
way so that it can be done in physical form
and if the individual wanted they could
shift his diet to the uniform I think that
they should should be able to do that too
I'm just trying to fill in figure it out u l
f s real quick though absolutely
it depends on how I depends it depends on
the size of the of the code that were using
right it's like
a better way to do this specific one I think
is to actually make a vagrant Cloud for this
thing which is
which is useful by everybody it's
racquetball I can put it on a resume and I
can refer to it I can refer to it in my eyes
that look at it and say oh I made a cloud I
made a cloud maker file out of that and so
instead of saying so we keep this overcast
and down to the notes then we should we put
artifacts cuz the goal of the end of the day
is creating artifacts that create Russ and
having a certain number of is it becomes
part of the regulator section absolutely
yeah hits right and actually what you're
talking about there is exactly what I did
earlier I I started putting you know all the
references and everything that I used to
find the solution to do the lab I put it I
put all that stuff in the zettelkasten and
then it is settled and then I and then I
linked to the lab and then the lab I was
okay to go check out the slab if you need
more stuff right and I think that is still
valid but ain't but the more I get drilling
down into it and I'm looking at the labs of
Mike
labs are like cluttering up my GitHub
there's nothing really value in them other
than they contain stuff that was used to get
me to a certain point so I need to stop
making a lab and I need to turn it into
something that I and others can use and and
making you not be allowed to see what I'm
getting at is I don't think Labs necessarily
neither will get rid of I think
I'm I'm I'm going to continue to do Labs but
my labs are going to be messy messy things
that'll eventually be be removed and
replaced and put in other places a
dissection like artifacts producing a slab
can be used in the following situations
right right I think you're right on that and
it depends on what am I thinking trying to
do is I'm trying to DM precise the over
creation of labs in any single person's get
refill because I think it
look at my my labs have been public because
I'm streaming right but most people I would
suggest that their Labs be all the labs are
as an extension of the code book idea that I
had a long time ago a code book idea is just
a single module that's got all of your messy
work in their right and the lab is just the
same idea you just do one repo per thing and
then you you put all your labs in there I
think most laps should probably be private
for people
I need this should be private I think a lab
is a personal exploration of
you know something
and I don't mean the specification of the
loudness is something we're still missing do
we need
do we need to have labs in addition to
projects and exercises
I feel like a lab is something that
somebody's something is somebody set sports
for them self
and I'm having a hard time with that one I
know I know people think I'm being pathetic
but I know these are things I can't talk
about I need to stand up stand up and go get
some food
but yeah that's kind of interesting
I learned a lot from those mistakes I know
that's why I'm saying so
I think we should probably keep the lab Dash
idea the other thing is really great about
11 in terms of digital resources you get to
see the commits as they happen
is it that is you know what I don't want to
Discount that that is huge so you can go
back and you can see the process of
discovery happen over the history of the
project
right
and that I think that's really valuable
particularly for for digital projects
if you're using get you know if you can get
if you're just if you're not using good
and maybe you wouldn't get that as as much
or as history
I like this one didn't have a lot but the
point being is that you can actually go back
and see okay what did I change hear what did
I get rid of what the night you know you can
the whole idea of using get to back that
stuff I think is really very well so I think
I might
I think I might be I think you might be
right right
yeah
alright well let's think about that then I
think keeping keeping alive around is
yep okay yeah I think I think we need lab in
here someplace I don't know
alive is a is a is a loose exploration of
skills or even a discovery of the skills
required
that's another thing about Labs that's not
covered here right this is all assuming that
there's a set number of skills what about
what about all the the the things in life
that people have to do where there are no
set the skills that the word for the skill
doesn't even exist yet because you're
discovering new things that need to be done
and learned that stuff is all discovered
during the lab process you made end up doing
a lab and discovering there's a digital
skills you need that don't even have a name
yet and and that's where you would add them
to your personal set of skills
can you put all your lives in a separate
aboard yeah I don't like that is just too
hard to research I can't send people search
the tool of course for visualizing your get
history I have not but sounds pretty cool
that sounds pretty cool it's called course
courses in Middle School oh my
oh I have seen this yeah I have seen it yeah
I saw this a while back actually
yeah it's it's fun is not fun
yeah I know that I saw it I know what yeah
my weed is the field trip to Davidson
College and they had all their source code
that way on the screen for the kids to see
yeah it's a super cool I didn't know that
was his name though
all right I'm going to walk away from it I I
think I'm going to keep labs
what we need to come up with if you want to
give us this some thought we need to we need
to figure out what
the collection of skills looks like and we
need to figure out a way to
to standardize that list the standardized
the list of skills that is the most core
thing and then we have to figure out a way
for an individual to maintain their own it
is naming the main modeling yeah then we
need to figure out what
yeah I believe we should keep it distributed
I don't if we're going to have a central
database of skills
I think it's more important that individuals
add skills to their own database
do I have an official was supposed to be the
people Fork
at some point we're probably going to need
that yes but I kind of want to keep it so
that it's not yeah but I don't
again I want people to be able to set their
only be able to do their own thing I kind of
feel like the awesomest database should not
be
yeah that whole thing where people provide
their own unique identifiers right so
somebody could have exactly the same ocms
Mustang right
we need to revisit this whole this whole one
the credential because
I know that it has multiple levels in terms
of stuff like that and I still want to do
that name your Elf
yeah I don't know I I'm just I think this
might be too heavy
I think it might be too heavy and I think I
might I might use it because it's too heavy
you know
you want I don't want any of its real bad as
I want to be able to go find badges but I
want them to be able to say hey I want to
use these badges or 4, using their own way
you know
so we need to manage all of the listing of
skills of the same way was a manager
software so
I don't know if I feel like the levels are I
really felt like the levels were a big
breakthrough before and
I realize now that it's very very very hard
to quantify the stuff and that we need to
get down to two just we need to find out
what the leaf elements of the system are
what is the smallest possible otamatone acq
what is the smallest possible thing in the
system
and I believe I believe it's a task it is
called a leaf to ask and and or at least go
and at least skill is one that cannot be
subdivided into other skills you know it is
at its lowest level
and we need to be able to distinguish
between skills and abilities and front when
I will not be able to put abilities in his
wall but
so so yeah
yeah I don't know I feel like I mean I like
this but I feel like I feel like it's over
engineered I do coming back out and I feel
like it's a little bit over engineered I
don't I don't want to over engine or things
I want to keep things simple and you know
it's a constant battle to do that right
I think these credentials this is so when I
was doing the badger specification this is
for a badge this is not for its skill that
makes sense
so I still want to have a badge and I
probably think the awesomest specification
can stand alone in terms of hate when I when
I created this I was imagining a merit badge
is like I want a level one in this merit
badge and I'm going to put this on my hat or
something you know I want a level 2 we know
of of like this merit badge what would it
look like right and I was completely being
driven by how would I write the requirements
yeah like get I want to get to get badge I
want to get the vagrant badge a bigger level
one only get the VIN badge I want to get the
links bad you know and then you get a
certain number of Badges and you get another
collected badge unless I still want to do
that but the badges themselves are composed
of skills right and
and that's that's one coming back to the
merit badges the merit badge this is where
we're kind of diverting for the merit badge
system them are better system says do 3 of a
do a b and c or Doody and any you know and
there's this massive you know recipe of very
very hard line things that you have to do to
get to fulfill the requirements and I still
feel like we need that but
the piece that doesn't have any structure
right now other than the thing I was just
showing you is is
the breakdown of the things that are done in
India during the merit badge what is the
breakdown of the tasks that are accomplished
what are the skills that are being the
skills knowledge and abilities that are that
composed together are being covered by a
badge and and and that's that's what I'm
trying to say and in that sense a badge is
kind of akin to a project or 21 or more
projects that lead to you know a badge right
and I think we should probably we keep that
we don't have a badge in here but I did have
certification so
you know a certification or a badge would be
you know if you did this this one or more
projects so this says that a project and
certification has at least one project and
it right and if you do that project to get
the serpent the point is is it is probably
more than that of the badge to the skills
you like the mapping of the badges this
kills ya bash Littleton badge now I'm going
to be going to ask you right so let's say
you get the badge badge if it would you do
to do that while I have to go meet the
requirements of the batch batch right and
that's a start and that's probably the best
thing you could give an employer you would
say hey here's what I did to get this batch
like in very specific detail right and there
is another follow-up question here right so
the follow-up question is what are what were
the skills involved in getting that badge
that are documented in the
documented in the projects and some projects
and exercises you didn't get the badge what
were the skills involved
and I still want to see a badge in terms of
like how many times did we hit this specific
skill so if you have like a project right as
a part of the fastest micaceous I do this
project that project and you do another
project and maybe have two projects that are
required for the badge and the two projects
both of them hit one skill and one of them
Just Hits one scale and but not another and
said that you've seen that one of the skills
is getting overly emphasized by that badge
and then you can kind of like highlight you
know and kind of even a visual mode how much
is a certain skill getting hit by a certain
activity so this badge includes an
overemphasis on X & Y skill and an under a
house on this scale or a minimal emphasis on
this scale the skills are the DNA of the
Arkham system you know what I mean yeah so
that the skills are there the DNA there
there
they're the stuff of the entire thing and
their the atomic elements of the things so
if you if you you know if if you go into an
activity always wanted to do is I want to be
able to see what skills did I just get this
activity I don't even know what's going on
right so I did a tivity and it then I go
back and I look at my skills what's the term
for
what's the term for the spectrometer I kind
of want to call it that actually
here's your skill spectrometer right so you
do this project and you're running through
the skills spectrometer and it will show you
the skills that are in their signature you
like a spectrometer is Right Place project
your experience for those badges love with
his up not just one bad for project
absolutely so so let's say you know what you
do is particular project or a badge in a
magical poster project ride in any as you
think about you can say running through the
skill spectrometer and it will show you how
what the elements are in the elements are
the raw skills in the project and this is
where you got your interests and so you can
bind together multiple in a project or
credentials or exercises that like that and
you can start to get a sense with a quickly
of what your coverage and you can actually
generate a a skills list based on how much
of the stuff you've hit and how highly
you've hit it and as soon as you get that
mean that I can I can visualize that just
isn't being amazing thing
because that you had this like massive list
of skills that's maintained by a community
and you know and then the badges are
associated with those skills and now you can
you can see how hot are heavy you are in a
particular skill-set whereas your mind
another one such a scripting for example so
I keep saying things like I'm about 60%
coder 40% Ops you know and that changes over
time to finish up what I'm doing and it
really literally does it literally changes
if I wanted to see a running the skill
spectrometer of all this stuff I've been
doing based on the labs and I've been doing
recently I've been doing very little go so
lately if you were to look and I imagine
some visualization of my skills breakdown
would be very heavy in the operation space
be very light in the coating spaced right
and if we figure out a way to tag or to
label or do any of those things so we can
Bubble Up certain skills so they have a
certain set of tags we can say things like
oh gosh what's my total percentage of coding
skills over the last six months and I might
got I'm like really
I need an operations in almost nothing and
encoding that is the original idea behind
skill Sac that is an idea I had in 2012 when
I was trying to get myself back up to speed
where I needed them and I needed to start a
rank my skill stack and see where I was that
was the original ideas that I can visualize
where I'm at like where my skills at and
where do I need to be so I need to be here
and here and here and I did it at a very
granular level and on paper originally but
then that's kind of where I want to go this
Ram expansion skip a level 3 complete the
badge until tomorrow's lessons
yeah
yeah and so is a XP exp boils down to the
other thing I want to add into the system
which is I know it's like real pie in the
sky but I want to add entropy and I have
tons and tons of notes on this is the most
of them are on my iPad I got to go find him
I want to add entropy I think if if you if
you put into this whole system if you put
the level of entropy on the skill you can
assign a certain skill a higher level of
entropy Decay and this I know this gets
really am right in fact there's probably
another business model idea and he recalled
get out of the skill spectrometer are the
spectrum of skills or whatever because
certain skills have a much higher Half-Life
than other skills right because they they
die immediately certain skills once you stop
doing them you you're you can't do them it
said you need to build the measure the
interview so that if you want to keep a
certain critical set of skills up to speed
you need to be able to go back to your
progress thing as a technologist to say oh
my God answer key on these skills is so
great I can't even coating for anymore I
don't know any Ruby it is completely decayed
my Ruby you know has completely Decatur I
don't know any of it anymore
because of the rate of Decay for Ruby at so
you can actually set for yourself of all the
languages flow toward art have higher to be
exactly if you set the amount of entropy of
a particular skill-set then you could go
back and say what I want to make absolutely
sure that I don't get too much decay in my
go coding for example right now what's the
last time I go to go I could go maybe once
every 2 weeks now there was a time when I
was cutting go 8 hours a day everyday and
the entropy on my go is significant it's
gone down I've forgotten it and if you want
to maintain your skill stack you've got to
know where you're at at any given time and
that means knowing what your estimated rate
of Decay Is On Any Given thing and that
should be that you can set your own level of
entropy you can you can have a base level 9
trophy as as as set by you know somebody out
there so you have to overly manage your
skill-set you know stack of things but by
having that I mean imagine visualizing that
you should be able to go and eat people say
I'm just a technical guide
well I mean I like graphic stupid that's a
good user Graphics you can have a grafana
dashboard or anything you can say here's
where I'm at to here's where I'm I've got in
trouble here you know I'm I'm decaying here
I'm underfed here I'm malnourished here you
know what I'm saying you could see right
away where you stand and then you can you
can work to adapt it and it would in the
process unit of game of finding the whole
the whole process of keeping your skills up
today it would all be game if I because now
it's a matter of hate I can't let my skill
tree two client here is like saying do do
where you learn a skill by getting XP but
then it goes away if you don't use it within
5 minutes
she know so just game if I don't think so
and I'm so sorry I just give you 5%. Or like
a multiple absolutely yeah and you would get
it would like up your game in a certain area
I actually exercise is things like exercises
to me I mean if we could set up a system
where the exercises are related to a school
right you if you want to build that skill
and you can do a project and project is
going to build the skills but it's sucking
it as it take down your interview as much as
doing repeatable exercise unless they want
to pump off a bunch of skills right so we
would set up small repeatable exercises that
focus on a specific number of skills just
like Coke code caught us or whatever and and
then you would do those skills and then you
would pump those things up your XP your
exterior you know you would they would get
really you know right I would imagine it's
what it would look like and that's cool with
getting really bright right where I was
doing a project yes it would take you up a
notch but it wouldn't it wouldn't be your
strength in that still wouldn't be as high
but it would probably but you know project
to actually add more to some
Nils which is another statistic which is
what is your what is your output mean
exercises don't produce output right
projects to produce output and output or
deliverables that is that is the that is the
thing is going to create rust right so you
have your raw skill ability which is your
skill-set New Year your you know how much
how what's your score in terms of like these
skills and and your ability to perform and
then you have your trust things which are
like and what percentage of things do I have
that prove I can do these things and that's
your deliverable so the exercise pumps are
still up and the project proves that your
skills pumped up and so you would want to
have a score that shows you have a really
high deliverable ratio in addition to a high
school ranking in a particular area m a n s
this obviously it would be a really great
application to make it some point but but
just
but just specifying the domain model for
come in after conversing about this stuff is
is a big piece of it without making it over
to the complex but in on a figure out what
to call it so forgetful we discovered Labs
today
and I T V I know we do with this isn't even
scratching the surface I know
I know aren't attractive things like brain
still think about this stuff that we're
talking about doing is
I actually am glad that this is coming out
of the software world are that you know the
tech world because that technologist have
already sold a ton of problems that that
then that makes her education I think the
thought of like like versioning knowledge
you know we've been doing that with read me
files forever now we can go back and we can
see when it changed and how it changed and
what date and astonishment things that are
that are that are generally you know focus
on any level Macadamia naked education
they're just not know we don't think of it
so we think about things in terms of scale
and sustainability we also over engineer
shit so this is where we need to bring in
somebody else I don't think that this
demesne model is going to make sense to
anybody
I'm at the higher educational or even in the
case of 12 education whatever I don't think
I'm going to give a shit until they see
something and what they're going to need to
see is an application that shows you know
how somebody can track their skills a person
first and they just go do an application and
and that application you know results and
his skill spectrometer that shows what they
know they'll get it
I can visualize that and I I can see the end
result of what it would look like and I know
that the end result once it's in a graphic
map of some kind would get terminal at least
one person listen to me right now and he's
like thinking about making an app that does
this right now
you know and I don't care if I mean if you
want to lift my model and everything it's
all attribution you have to make sure you
and please let me know how much as we should
but but this this kind people have tried to
do this thing and they all fail everybody
who's trying to do this has failed that I've
been I've encountered I looked at a lot of
educational you know tracking systems and
stuff like that and they all suck and the
reason they suck is because they're built
their bills by the theorist theorist ditions
you know and academics in people like that
and they're not they're not built by people
who are used to composing and and
aggregating and doing things in the cell
phone frankly they're not suffering years
and I think the software Engineers have a
distinct Advantage when you coming up with
this kind of stuff because we are masters of
organizing complex things that's what
software engineering is an end so if we can
figure out how to organize complexity and
make it appear simple and have it it's a
butterface I think that we'll have a leg up
on on on what can be done and then we can
prove
in in in in in the most basic terms that can
possibly get and then go presented its tea
or something like that for this
International Society for taking education
which is pretty much the perfect for him for
this because it's a bunch of technologist at
the instructional techno and Specialists
like that these are the people in education
at least in America that are focused on
bringing tattoo to further education in the
world and they're even if we don't strictly
speaking or going to put this in text terms
they will get it because they they tend to
be the most you know technically thinking
group in in the in the education space lease
in America so
so I think I think we're getting close to
this ad what is it mean for me in terms of a
welcome what does it mean for me in terms of
what I organized this here I'm going to take
a break yeah for sure I think I think I
think the the the first thing out of this is
I need to figure out how to capture a skill
in a very simple way I need you to I'm out
of here
I think a break c a b
yeah I will be there in a heartbeat if I
wasn't married
whether you could stop over there
I wish more Educators streamed text energy
do
cuz of expats in Netherlands I got her in a
heartbeat
we're not we're going to stay here we're
going to move the pendulum but
Penland that's her own movie
yeah it's crazy how easy it is to move
around if you have Tech skills I looked at
that one was going to think we were talking
about moving to Toronto
7 of 8 criteria for a fast track in your
your immigration papers in Toronto and in
all of them were Technics
yeah
you know that's one of the things Tech
skills give you and gives you the
opportunity to explore
I am particularly since you can do it
remotely right
and I like I mean this Apartments been fine
but I'm kind of done with it I get a nice
little cottage in the mountains
my big ass Warehouse happy will come over
and visit
stay with us artists in tech people
cuz I'm old now start settling down we're
going to do it though it's going to happen
I'm telling you
life goals my life goal is to be able to
have our next conference or a skillset
conference
I'm sorry brand is kill snack by the way
also key part of the artifacts is Me by
Victor Robbins me and then still sex going
to be the bigger thing
it's cuz I have all that all those Brands
stuff done
Shuffle City
is money where we're moving to Amazon. Who
knows
I need to learn to flow talk to Rooms doing
some
getting num num
I don't know. Remember I'm going to follow
him you going to say something is when he's
going to be like oh no
what what do you say
I think he's afraid I'm going to write him
he's waiting in queue I haven't these.
Spectrum I'm about to haven't found him
before
all right my back yet I guess I'm back I'm
back
yeah I'm back
I do need to go to bed pretty soon though I
can't accept past like 3:30 or so because I
need to sleep cuz I need to be up to my love
me cuz I want to do anime tomorrow too
you know I have to figure out how to figure
out how to get it so that Discord saves with
the vod's
I'm thinking how to do that yet I know how
to figure out how to do that yet so
how can I pick up later that's kind of tired
I feel like we talk to it so here's the
here's the primary thing I need to figure
out what to do and then I think I can leave
this
and she on what we talked about I agree to I
just had some food it's going to make me
tired I'm going to fall asleep
we need to figure out how the most important
thing here
is how to take a lab that I've done like and
squeeze out of it a list of skills
that can go into a file and then eventually
be combined with another file
and maybe for a given individual they can
keep their own lists in their own file and
then those things can be aggregated up and
combined with everybody else's eventually
and that's that's the most important thing
you think it would be room for incorporating
our lady will transfer his skills to know
they're still absolutely
TV the buy the actually I think I think all
that stuff needs to be done but I don't want
to get bogged down in too many you like side
properties
and
there's a lot I think it's skill game when
we think about scales let's just get
straight down to it a skill is a bullet
point in a job listing
quite frankly I want to make a limitation on
a scale so that it has to befeel so that it
has to be able to be expressed in 152
characters
because if you can express his skill under
52 characters you will get your leaf
and that also by the way would allow people
to write job descriptions very quickly you
think of any job description they could say
you know it's got to check on the check
boxes I imagine quick and all the check
boxes and all the skill and it's a yes I
want you sent all this and then boom and
then just like boom they got their job
description and then they could take it have
it because people are not going to digest
stuff if it's more that fact I'll go so far
as to say that
a skill fundamentally is something you can
describe in under fifty two characters now
is probably has a long summary or
description and entropy has all these other
properties to go with it but ultimately this
guy needs to needs to be just out of town so
if if if you or anybody if anybody wants to
take a stab at the data model either Indiana
or Jason or whatever right or even Json
schema if somebody if any of you want to
take a stab at
at the data model for a skill
there are 30 people right here yeah
everyone's homework yeah I know I've just
been I've been picking on you because you've
been really interested in it but anybody if
anybody wants to try to think about what is
a skill what are the properties of the scale
we don't want to go too overboard because
when somebody adds a new skill to the
database they should be able to just start
with OK here's the title and then if they
need to then come back to it later
yeah NFL Nation agree
but here's the thing with this guy the
reason I keep going back to the title is
because that's what goes in the job listing
right it's the easiest thing to it's the
most intuitive thing you know and you're
going to we don't want people to be too
critical of the school list that they create
a front because they going to take too much
time building the skill list in order to be
really messy and fast and so you say okay I
did this lab here's the skills I feel like I
did too until they do some skills summary at
the end of their Lab at the beginning of his
that he was the skills that I learned it
here right and then they they throw them up
they throw them up one line at a time and
they throw them into their skills database
and then they start to realize how I already
got this other one here that's kind of like
this other one here and then they
manipulated we don't want to bug people down
by creating their skill this because
creating the skillet is what is is what's
going to stop people from doing this but if
we can get them to just pause for a little
moment as their summarizing their lab after
they're done with it or after the project as
like here's the skills that I am a kind of
formula the formula
like a way of thinking about this as during
that summation kind of moment but they look
stop for a second and describe what you just
learned in terms of how this would go on a
resume what are the job bullet points that
you would write about that you just learned
from this
and every 4th to go to think in terms of
those line items without bogging and down
with all the extra properties of a skill
like it's entropy and all that stuff will
get more contributions to the skills
database indirectly and then we can come
back and we can flesh out okay this skill of
the clarification of the description should
be pretty obvious from the title but you
know I'm saying we can get people to do that
I think I think we really only go on and
still doing one hour day month nice
Advance knowledge absolutely I don't think
you need Advanced that's the whole point of
a skill that skill is like insert here's a
skill
insert a data insert a row into a database
that's a skill
right it's also a task in that case a task a
task is insert this specific row into a
database what were the skill is a function
as a procedure
and the execution with a given number of
arguments is a task
and it's great you know sunrise on this but
tomorrow come back to it what we're doing
here is where we're eating humans is what
we're doing we're coding humans
and when and when you write the steps the
method of a skill
you know what does it mean to say insert
into database it's broken down into further
down into further statements for the methods
and attributes yeah we are coding humans
individual skill standard
entry management yeah yeah I guess Tanners
individual skill centers and they tied that
you normally do you need to tell me more
about that that's because the government's
really good at doing that kind of
she got no wine instead of to you requiring
occurring be a scale rather than rather than
the database in itself
I don't know
yeah they're really good at this stuff dead
some say they they've had to do this right
because they have to categorize the shit out
of this if they're probably too much so and
by the way you know the Boy Scout merit
badge system for the Boy Scouts of America
was largely inspired by the military so
knows how to get people practical skills
that's their fucking Focus
and so many people come into the IT world
from the military because because they are
all about practical skills
so I can chip assisted Academia which is why
hippies are always fighting with soldiers
with the Air Force and hated math of the
passion came back in Signal intelligence
analysts aren't trying to tell you yeah yeah
you learn practical things it is ago she ate
you know it was him bro and then he's got
his losses theoretical math anything white
because now he realize I was going to help
him push it up or whatever
I use the skill right yes so let's kill this
kill is this is this is akin to a function
or procedure and coding the execution of
that procedure is a task am I'm in my way of
thinking in my way of thinking it's a task
what you got there
car computer security crime as guide
thank you for sharing speaking of military
wow this is a great document
shit can I have this I'ma download that
I'm putting my list of PDFs
help me get my c k s
isn't classified
it's like Bill Hader you know that whole
skit with Bill Hader
nice yes
there it is I now have it when I got his
titles way too fucking long
how computer and security
or Scurry climates guide
yeah
hello all the way that now it's on my
computer and blinding me
oh God I only just for the computer away I
really do
I love you to the summer time I can pick her
up before I hurt myself
oh that's much better
Peter Drucker write about the roundabout way
why you can't see it cuz I'm zoomed in there
we go going to move that the f s
well what is a January horseshit with shit I
got the latest hot off the presses
hot off the presses
if you have Raiders this I don't know
I the one that's on the computer enter the
Vault 1
is it a fault no more time pop OS whatever
that is
and I can't even tell you because I just
open it in in my system knows because this
my default application for
no ask me is it hard questions about
document viewer out of that
document viewer 4.01 events is a document
viewer for Gnome
events apparently copyright the event events
authors
ha she terminology she is a big big fucking
deal I got to read this
she smokes and then yeah
yeah see that this is me Kim Chi stroking
through
Sarah space defenses response
noise yeah I'm up there I got to go take you
so much for your help
I think I'm going to go I'm going to set for
myself going forward is after I finish the
lab when I ask myself two things what are
the skills that I just did in this lab
even if it's a failed lab and
what are the deliverables from this lab that
may or may not be better suited someplace
else so in the case of my NFS lab I'm going
to make a big rain cloud file out of that
and I'm going to put my nose to myself
casting
that's it that's it and I need it I need to
figure out where to keep track of my skills
I miss some file I need to create a file
somehow that super easy to edit that I can
just go in there and add my skills to it and
just create a like a really messy skills
list
yam or otherwise I don't know but cuz I
don't want to spend too much time
on that it wasn't what do it
another one nobody else I think that's the
biggest failure like that I B M system for
skills management was fucking disaster and
it was because we had to spend hours
listening always goes in there
and it wasn't tripping based on Project yeah
I could have came a section
this is the kind of shit that I might
actually want to read just cuz
40 OD will a clock and getting along with
security controls are Grandmas as Siri
I feel like I feel like I'm going to make
this mandatory meeting for myself as I go
into the cks
which is going to be the last sort and I get
but at the mall by July but that'll be the
last one right
I kind of want to read this cuz I feel like
it's going to give you my love what are you
think there's a get dizzy get down and dirty
and the community stuff
he did me the committee sectional
city manager meeting absolutely agree if
you're going to do security. You should read
it right again this is the kind of thing
that I don't think he's a special security
analyst boost right I think this is the kind
of thing if you have any prescriptions you
know you better fucken read it you know you
just you need the security is a part of
everything else it's not some extra thing
that you add on either going to make a
career out of pen testing or something like
that then yeah that separate but security
needs to be an integral part of every
section of that so then we're talking about
go programming we should talk about how
Security is to do this can you use file
system flocking you know things like that
those are in there were always talking about
the security of it and at the same time
we're covering hacking topic because while
why was talking about security were also
talking about how to own it and somebody
doesn't do that we talked about that was
pointers or even the sea stuff and had first
date we talked about a lot of hacking
techniques without talking about them
explicitly you know we talked about in a
memory overflow and stuff like that so I
don't think you need specific instructions
on security and this is for the Boost I
think you just need to have it as a part of
everything and that would be one of these
documents would be and document covering the
nitty-gritty details of in government speak
of cybersecurity as it applies to Cloud
Outsource it processes oh my God don't even
get me started on this do they have policy
recommendations with regard to like
Outsourcing shit
that has got to be the single greatest
vulnerability that in America
I don't even want to talk about it because
the dod is going to get mad at me
we're talking about our massive honour that
when I was at i v m shut the stuff I saw go
down
I mean I'd access that access to systems
that when I was in Boulder I got it I got a
tour and I got to see a ton of unmarked
systems inside of older the Builder Fuller
serverlab
and I know what they are I can't talk about
it but
I talked a little bit about the point of
trying to make is
you guys know what happened to Sonia I do
not give me the war
composite world as well
it arises have his face yeah well
the biggest the biggest security
vulnerability in America you want to know it
give me the number to biggest security
vulnerability in America is to tell you to
tell you what it is you don't know how to
attack America
I'm using all the keywords that are going to
get me in trouble
the biggest security vulnerability in
America is outsourcing services hands down
it is by far the biggest single point of
vulnerability in all of America in my
opinion
and this there's no checking there's no
wedding of contractors there's a huge
cover-your-ass culture that doesn't give a
shit about security it's like how they can
limit their own personal liability cover
liability there is no accountability
whatsoever and I I can give you very
specific incidences of how this is true
the the level of critical infrastructure
yeah
yeah because we Outsource everything we
don't even check it
I'll give you one Quicksilver this okay it
is kind of a fun bedtime story
all right this is bedtime story I mean
Outsourcing yeah I noticed that this is like
the dod's number one thing Outsourcing it
base process is right
it Services I have a feeling I don't know I
haven't read it yet but I have a feeling
they're going to go off on this
because it's so bad
Hunter's Contracting with a c s p are
Outsourcing all or a portion of the
information to go anywhere close to the CSP
this is the same as you see the IT services
so
all this is over our service offerings may
be inheriting controls and compliance from
the third-party the priciest Bia to see his
beer in the greater with a DOD contract for
service it wasn't responsible for completing
compliance
this applicable applicability statement and
Associate requirements are consistent with a
DVD in federal acquisition of crime is a
Clauses which state does DOD contractor in
the case of the most secluded security
requirements are coming up on it this
paragraph right here this this hit big news
it was a ton ton is probably gone by now
always there are they over there and tell me
what you remember
do you just hit news previously
when was I want to say it was 18 months ago
when I was looking at the security space I
read an article about
the explosion
explosion of security needs based on the
government's new requirement that providers
to the Department of Defense had to fulfill
minimum requirements for security
including Baseline certifications in like
Security Plus through Pearson and stuff like
that and then it it trickled down it
actually caused up until that point there
was no requirement whatsoever forgetti
providers and contractors to meet any
security crime it's at all at least that's
what the articles about I mean it was I
could be remembering it wrong but it was it
was basically
yeah
and you haven't dig a genetic marker I don't
know you don't have to at all yeah I don't
think so I mean Leon Panetta a very famously
and dramatically said that's the equivalent
of a Pearl Harbor is taking place all the
time on the cybersecurity front and I think
it's a stealthy War though nobody's going to
know about it
Modern Warfare is happening all the time
everyday and we just aren't you going to go
look at the map on Twitch to the shows all
the dudes DDOS attacks that are coming from
China
are happening all the time it didn't promise
we're not we're not seeing it Johnny Johnny
Papa
is it tell me about or tell me why
like this probably fedramp in it going with
you
if it is pronounced with it. I've been
saying Tony while instead of time
I'll sit down if I from now on
I thought if I could be heard for certain
senior positions I say suck plus yep yep and
but it's more than that right so
and pierces got all the government contracts
like a bedtime story so we we is Christmas
time
we're getting ready to play our huge data
model migration over to something we called
devcentral and we managed a pretty large
a lot of operation for the Enterprise not
just one Enterprise all tons daily The
Fortune 500 companies we are cell phone is
running on there to do auditing and it would
gather data on it would dump it into our
database that I modeled some out of the
whole fucking thing I wish I had a diagram
of that it was so big she said and then I
would migrate that day that periodically
over to decentralize you be too and then
that will go into some big big ass jobs for
doing all kinds of analysis and stuff
against you know all of our customers and
our security compliance and everything is
pretty fucking amazing system I love that
being part of it and
it's a it turned out that
did the guy the contractor the lead
contractor
for all the TV to work who is he was working
with with the other group, sister group to
ours and interface with him pretty regularly
we didn't do any of you to suffer on Post
Road and
but this this guy who is responsible to do
this job to do this migration that had tons
and tons of like really in critical audit
systems and data on it and it was going to
keep their database tub just disappeared
our Christmas you just disappeared nobody
knew where it was
I'm not getting nobody knew nobody knew
where the guy was they eventually found him
he was
apparently like drunk and passed out or
something like that in a ditch someplace he
was still alive and he just he had he had
mental health issues and all the stuff and
Horton Tire system was dependent on this one
guy
who had been a contractor who was completely
and that it and I felt sorry for the guy and
there was another what they contacted his
family and everything and they claim that he
was going off the Alpha Project and
everything after that because it's like
major major critical upgrade had to happen
independently on this guy and it occurred to
me that time I mean it wasn't anything
horrible tragedy on his part. I'm not I'm
not judging him but I was in that moment
that I realized how fucking vulnerable our
key critical
key critical systems are in America
didn't think you would know you would know
the companies that we dealt with every day I
had access to their internal financial data
and they are out of compliance on every
fucking one of their service at the mission
add root access to every server in the
entire group of servers 52,000 servers
across multiple companies and I had root
access to everyone I was writing I was
writing software that was doing audit
compliance that needed to get this
information from all those servers and
therefore I indirectly had access to every
one of those servers
and you know if I
you know it we we talked about this before I
am scared of having the same conversation
again I remember I told the Story Once Upon
a Time before there's no checks and balances
if I had died or if that person is died or
that person had decided they wanted to take
down
I mean it was just a database administrator
right it means that there they could have
destroyed the entire database is you hear
about the the intern who like destroyed like
truck and there was nothing in the news last
week
yeah did you read that one
oh god oh you know what you just you just
kind of like cringe right
so so so so I'm not I'm not encouraging
people to do this but if you want to attack
America or any other country
Outsourcing you say to it you get a job for
teksystems
you get you get you get an international
Visa you get an international visa and you
get a job for a work visa if you work for
you if you want it 70% of American ID
systems the day I read in in Silicon Valley
are run by expats the stuff they're being
run by experts are non non American foreign
Nationals
the first to get repoed his company was
using oh yeah that one too
I like I've been under a rock or many of
these things that most people aren't
I just remember this specific incident
because because
it was in that moment that I realized how
totally fucking vulnerable we are
I mean none of these these contractors that
were higher that had root access to all of
these military grade some of that I will say
right now some of the accounts are military
some the accounts were hi-hi-hi and Banks
wear if they were to take the bank down or
able to craft our financial system they were
very very high-end systems and these
contractors who were working on these
systems had no wedding whatsoever they were
just hired off the street from Texas and
without any wedding without a security
clearance at all
if you were to try to get access to those
systems through regular government channels
you know to to be able to administer those
systems of stuff like that you would have
gone through several levels and probably and
I'm I'm guessing I'm guessing that those a
lot of these systems were were not as
classified I'm sure that I can't possibly
believe that the government would put that
much you know like seriously classified
information but they sure don't give a shit
about our financial welfare and and the
banks and stuff that we had our corporate
finance stuff and all that over there there
at all and mortgage this is a list of all
that stuff was just running completely
unprotected when it's protected but it's not
protected against the people doing the
protecting
people doing the protecting the contractors
that are hiring for you know 40 bucks an
hour off the street don't have any wedding
whatsoever and they have direct access to
all of these internal huge corporations
so you know it's like I just I can't
overstate how vulnerable we are there is no
wedding of any of our biggest point of
failure is not the fucking firewalls it's
not that our biggest point of failure is HR
and if you don't believe me just look at the
news right now about all the open-source
ship is going down it's all hr-related it's
all related to people people are the
security vulnerability they always have been
they're way bigger than anything else
they're going to do stupid shit they're
going to commit stuff to their public Repose
they're going to do a solar winds and then
I'm going to vet the vet the code because
I'm going to automate CI CD and then I give
you
see the crazy ass Bay 64 strains that
shouldn't even be there then I couldn't see
anything because it's a human factor this
going to cost us to fill and it continues to
be it's going to be that way for a long time
I don't know how they're going to fix it
frankly it's it's that whole cicd it's like
I have this huge password system that I
manage my mom was like you know the next
frame has so many that club and they beat
him to death what's the password the humans
are always a single point of failure
Yeah Yeahs Yeahs Yeahs yeah
they love to give me they found out they're
still using it so you deleted it God
yeah it's it's it's the humans the humans
are always you can you get one person go
postal so to speak on an internal it system
who has access to like I gave you anything
about IBM is that the taxes that I had to
stuff crossed multiple corporate boundaries
we have big arguments about whether we
should have multi-tenancy or not
because you could we can manage the same
audit data in the same database and I said
fuck no I'm not doing that this data needs
to go in a separate database I'm not going
to collect audit data for one company that's
going to be right next to the other
company's data in the same fucking date of
this I'm not doing that but there was no
there were no there was nothing telling us
to do that no but there was no proceed out
of this I am not doing it all so I didn't
let any of my audit data-at-rest unencrypted
all of my data at rest was encrypted and
then they bought bigfix and they all their
data at rest was totally fucking in the
clear and I was like why the fuck are you
using this is shit this is absurd shit and
you know how it was easier it was it was a
business decision the time and then they
sold it off like he was later I found out so
you know if you the single point of failure
due to human factor
and that you want at a company or place you
attack of the people you get you have
somebody to become a text message in your
and then you you let him work on a team you
make sure I'm there on the right team and
now boom they've got access to 2 dozens if
not hundreds of of really high-end root
level systems for corporations then you just
accidentally sneeze one day and they all go
to that they all go down
so bad it's just so scary God help us if we
actually do things like put on our power
grid and shit on that because
that's the thing where it gets really scary
did you see the prediction they made, who
made it
there is like I think it was Gartner group
they suggested that within the next five
years we'll have our first significant
cybersecurity event which will cause loss of
human life
and that's what's going to take to get
everybody to give a shit
so far we've had entire power grades go down
we've had a tire pipelines go down without
it affect the economy through gas shortages
we've had hospitals go down and people have
indirectly died because of ransomware
attacks but it has the the the the cyber
security attack hasn't directly killed
people
but the first time we get a cyber war attack
that directly kills people
that'll be our Pearl Harbor Event & in the
whole world's going to wake up El
everybody's going to be at it we're going to
be putting money in it and doing the right
thing right now or not that's why I didn't
leave his side to security for the Pentagon
step down he stepped down he's like I'm not
doing this to you guys are putting any money
into this we're going to get fucking don't
want to be any part of it
MercyMe stay up summarizing but that
actually happened last year last year he
stepped down as like no you guys are just
refusing to treat the seriously I don't want
a part of it and he walked away so we're
reading a reading at the reason this topic
is going on
how much does supposed to do it I don't know
man
people smacking their cars I don't know
I don't know man it this is why this is why
the right to repair issue is so complicated
it's not as easy as I don't I don't I'm not
saying that I'm an typewriter repair I'm
play razor repair I'm just
what the hell
I just I don't know I feel like
I feel like if I feel like I feel like that
issue is more complex than then
unclassified
suppose you had some clothes and a broker
the Secret Service prime contractor
I could I could I can ride like this I just
don't like it
we have to like you know put on your big-boy
government pants and write like a
track somebody who writes the Enterprise
corporate piece of shit I can't be able to
speak plainly you know I hate it when people
have to like put on their government speak
or legal speak you know and all that I mean
I know how to do it it's just like why the
fuck are you doing
what's that
do you have to bake brownies with another
ethical hackers pentest as long as
La what the fuck are you saying why don't
you just say what you mean
sexy pretty straight for writing it's the
acronyms it going to get you
and you kind of need the acronym so because
of the way you have to write it out
it's funny is I wonder why I wonder how many
people actually read this report
yeah that's okay you like thousands of
dollars to prepare report like this and then
I always wonder how many people actually
read it
cuz reading is hard right it's like we can
we created this report you're supposed to
follow the report and then like the number
of people who actually read it like all the
politicians you don't read that they don't
read those bills are like $607 pages long
they came to like it the week before that
the vote on it and it's like 700 pages long
as the weather read that shit
history of the problem people don't speak
plainly anymore they like
Keaton Raleigh car service writer vs. tsp
is that for your days
it did yesterday s p f all right
if yours is right in any form of the vfa
kidding me
the same disease I mean what's the deal they
all have the same
I don't know what it is I know it's like
somebody's getting paid by the page
it is self-importance is what it is
I know it's like I can write like this I
choose not to as much as I can do no I mean
having a big old camera and using an
unnecessarily or two different things
it's it's totally different it's just you
know
this kind of shit just discussed me from
people that are my age I occasionally I'll
run into somebody who is my age 54 and 1/8
absolutely no they would look down as soon
as being juvenile and then an unsuccessful
cuz I don't have a million-dollar home or
some shit I absolutely know they look down
on me on that I've been just considering
this recently and then I could have gone
that route I could have learned to speak you
know legally use and and all of this and
yeah and
because dedicated funny bugs
oh I think Pinterest you still going to be
able to go cuz it's cheaper
pen pen testing but possessing bug bounties
it's going to be cheaper I'm going to put my
I put my bed on that
the becoming is assuming and pay it to
remediate to have to pay him twenty grand
for one bug is a drop in the bucket compared
to paying a full-time security team to look
at everything they're going to start having
to Tip Top the game with our security teams
but but most companies the money it's all
about the greed right it's all about the
money to let him money money money right so
so what's cheaper for an organization's
right so if you're a CTO and you just care
about your job and then keep anything else
we going to do
you're going to rush something to Market so
you can get more money and look better than
everybody else because you've beaten the
market and I can make it secure than what
you going to do you going to sit back in
your going to wait on you to put a big ass
bug bounty on anything that goes wrong in
any event is somebody actually find
something wrong you quickly paid to have it
fixed in your like a manageable risk manager
will risk the bug Bounty people make out
great the people who spend less money for a
security team that have to pay full-time and
then you have to listen to me whine about
all the things that they need to do to
improve their security because obviously
it's f a f a bounty hunter can't find it
it's not a problem right that's how that's
how pointy hair ultra-rich executive
corporate people think
they don't give a shit about coming your ass
and making more money and men and that
culture is just prevalent is just prevalent
in all of corporate America and everywhere
frankly and I think I think for that reason
I discover this probably a year-and-a-half
ago I was thinking about this really
seriously about the future pentesting I was
like is it going to be in his only so many
bugs to find right and then everybody going
to find them all they're going to go away
and companies are going to get wise up and
going to hire security teams and then
there's this whole bug Bounty you know
independent bug Bounty career kind of things
and go away
I don't think so I don't think so anymore at
all I think this financial incentive to
continue to pay Independence is going to
drive it and then The Independents are going
to remain motivated because they can make
crazy as money did you can find like a
simple ass little bug that is already
disclosed by the vendor and read the vendor
thing do ask and find a bug has already been
disclosed by the vendor that the company's
to fucking lazy to do anything about cuz
they don't have a security team internally
they even check to see if they're vulnerable
you do a Basics can you find a bug and make
3 Grand and if you don't believe me go look
at all the people on YouTube have cashed in
doing this
because this is gobs and gobs of crazy as
money Toni Toni Toni if all I was just
saying about how they he there they're
analyzing the buggy found a Google is going
to get bigger and get paid make on that one
it is it just Outsourcing testing on the
most important thing security you know
they just they just do and then you know
and then the other people are making crazy
money just see the I like this though some
of the some of the biggest hackers in
history has named their now running their
own bug Bounty set up programs
so they've been that not only are they
making money on the bug man anything they're
making their making crazy crazy executive
corporate bank by Consulting with fat cat
corporations about how to set up their own
bug Bounty programs
and it's absolutely brilliant because
they're making money by finding the bugs
during bug Bounty programs and they're
making money teaching the companies and
lobbying frankly the copies to stick with
implementing bug Bounty programs instead
instead of doing the proper thing they
should do by building an internal system
so they're they're just laughing all the way
to the bank oh my God
she is laughing all the way to the bank
because they're speaking the love language
of the corporation
money feel like we're going to save you a
ton of money now we're going to do it we're
going to make it so that you can find bug
Bounty you can fight people other than your
independent committees going to find all
your bugs for you and you're not going to
have to pay anything but Nick is doing that
and the other big guy he's found a bunch of
0 days in cyber words doing that yeah
there's a bunch of people these
these people that were hackers before so
this is how it went down used to be a few
were black hat you were bad person you went
to jail and then you got hired by the
government that would be midday can much
mother's right
no the people that's why cats now. Now the
black cats are right in their own ticket
with money because they're like is all the
sudden pain testing and Bug band legitimised
blackhat
so now you got all these black cats that are
like holy shit I can make crazy got some
money doing this and then you have other
black hats are like wow I can actually teach
corporations about how to get black hats to
work in their favor and I can sell that shit
all day because it's it's very appealing it
brought some 300 out right about yeah
yeah or it your letter if you're in Israel
to get forced to do hacking because you're
part of an elite military unit and you
become the best actress in the world that's
Israel top top security cameras in the
entire world or continue to be held in
Israel because they've got a war
and yes so it's if I mean it was buying
stocks that pretty clear on that and some of
the best sex that was absolutely phenomenal
bring it 30 days in that
Sarah s one of the best in the world then
you don't it where is that is that it is
real
is that is that one of the ones in Israel
yeah
yeah I didn't know about that one but I I
know about the military
end of the military's cyber security force
in Israel as is like world-renowned and this
has nothing to do with Jewish versus at
Palestinian or any of that it's not that.
It's just it's just a state of affairs it's
it's pants down it's about 7 but it makes
Russian to Chinese look like they're tiny
little babies
it's seriously these people and it was all
you'll hear one of them talk and there's
like a an Israeli hacker who talks about how
when he was a kid he didn't like to play
games you just like to hack
and yeah
all I can say is an American is some kind of
glad Israel is still sort of one of our
allies I mean I feel bad about the State of
Affairs in Palestine wish we could be more
equally associated with that I have nothing
against them at all but God damn what I hate
to have Israeli hackers targeted America
there probably are we are
I'm at the train has one thing but then
heaven is real go after you with their
actress feels that would that would that
would be dangerous they've proven it was
sucks that can you imagine fuck they blew up
an entire uranium enrichment plant with a
hack
they blew that shit up they took that thing
out they blew it up from a hack
they got they got the Rainy mix they got
that you can see there's like tons of sensor
coverage on it
they got came from us yeah we did get a lot
of food is too if that's true
yeah but yeah
they say there's three that you read about
the stuxnet hack it was discovered by Norton
by the way it was earlier but is it was it
Norton Symantec no it was supposed to go to
buy Symantec
they hacked every fucking computer in the
world in order to do sucks that and that's
how we heard about it cuz semantic found it
and it it hacked the firmware of the uranium
and Richards so that they would accelerate
past their their safety limits and over
accelerate and blow up and spin out of
control and they hacked the systems that
showed where they were they were out of
their control they actually hacked the
monitoring systems as well so that they were
totally totally Trojan so that they didn't
even know it was happening
oh my God it was like so beautiful and so
fucking terrifying
ohoh I got it I just did level of skill to
do that I don't have nowhere near that
is there a Gap yeah I know and the whole
thing was there gapped
the whole thing was there. That means the
only way it got in so it's the first of all
the stuff that got out right so sucks that
the virus for sucks that infected every
computer in the world pretty much that's how
they found it cuz semantic found it and
they're like what the fuck is this saying
this isn't doing a normal regular things and
then so what ended up happening is somebody
got their USB infected from their home PC
and then they took their home PC in to work
one day and they plugged into the internal
air gap thing and they they they blew up the
entire the entire uranium enrichment
deliver the thing is so terrifying about
that is the level of which they were willing
to compromise the security of the entire
fucking world just to do one attack
every single system in America was
compromised by sucks that that's how they
found it
that's how they found it because they they
they deliberately attacked every system and
it didn't hurt any of us none of us got hurt
none of us got hurt bad but it was detected
as a virus in like what the fuck is this
saying to do anything being semantics like
what you got there's a whole entire cyber
War series episode just on stocks that and
they interview the guy from Symantec who
discovered it's absolutely amazing it's
absolutely amazing the reason I liked it so
much this is because it's a level of
cyberwarfare that actually came to light in
the public Arena I imagined it like stuxnet
is going down every year and we have no idea
that was the only reason we know about that
one the only reason we know about that one
is because it hits so publicly and it got
picked up you out of my stuff yeah that one
got picked up by somebody if that if that
hadn't got and I think it's probably because
it got out of its I don't think it was
intended it to hit everybody probably
I think it was originally intended to
everybody if I receive Medicare and bottarga
new single person yeah
you know who is also Rising summer North
Korea yeah I know and a stuffed terrifying
yeah I mean I'm not I'm not trying to be
dramatic but this is
stuxnet was just one thing that we saw it
was just one thing that that that actually
bubbled up into the mainstream and look at
its complexity 30 days and look what it did
and it just makes you wonder
how much it just like stuff that is going on
that thing is like 17 years old now
center 8 years old in solarwinds was in a
bad but it wasn't nearly as bad as I
imagined is actually happening there there's
then there's no way we'll ever know because
that's because it's gets all that war is not
happening with like lots of like embedded
press and explosions and a kinetic were kind
of likely venue it's not it's not going to
happen that way you never going to have
embedded journalist in the Cyber word to be
able to blow the whistle on everything is
going down right that's that's not going to
happen the closer we're going to get is
there going is fuck up and it's going to go
outside of its boundaries and stuff that's
going to get picked up rush I ran their all
their yeah and it's it's It's Goin Down it's
going to be a big deal
yeah that is a hall effect yeah
yeah I know 7 years 7 years is tucked in or
so and this is the stuff they're doing right
now
you can't even possibly Majid
what I would really love to see you and
there's no way I could ever study this site
this would be fun to study but I don't have
the brain for it I wish I did I would really
love to study how I mean quite as I was
going to affect all of this but I would
really really love to study how I just
machine learning and Generals going to
affect the cybersecurity landscape because
we're already starting to see machine
learning helping the defense by tracking
patterns that are out of out of sorts the
saying hey that patterns not right we're
going to shut that down and they're tracking
patterns of behavior with employees and
stuff like that
companies in the security concerns as a
reason to just leaving everybody who doesn't
your dad can Windows
a little extra pieces for Saturday
guy fishing and the people are by far the
most vulnerable that doesn't make him at 2
it it's not the truth
it's not the truth of the matter is is they
want to spy on you and there's power doesn't
work on Linux that's why I can't use Linux
my company just sent me a brand new Macbook
Pro
because I can't use the facilities bpn
doesn't work
let me talk to VPN let me so too does not
work with Cisco anyconnect VPN the end it's
broken and so I said it doesn't work maybe
if you know so we can connect and they said
well yous buddy I said no and they said okay
here can use a smack then
so our offense machine learning yeah
yeah there's no data I think you're right I
think that's I think you're right machine
Machinery doesn't work without gobs and gobs
of data
and does not indeed work with a did you have
that problem to quietest
did you have that for same problem that
makes me feel very good because I I had to
go out and read tons of other people have
the same problem so I can just go back to my
teeth I was talking the same what do you
mean it doesn't know it doesn't work any
connected to the end and like well why are
using that I don't use potty I might because
I want to use you know doctor on my laptop
actually no I want to use that you're
selling my laptop instead of putty
why would you want to do that because it's
this isn't a book this is this is a
this is a summary of
this is the recommendations to the United
States government for cybersecurity from the
Department of fence at cloud computing
security requirements guide if you want to
do cloud computing and you want to work at
the Department of Defense you have to know
all of this and if you want to deal and
Cloud at all
you better fucken know this stuff so go
download it I think we saw the link
someplace
I think I might still have it oh yeah there
it is there's a link if you want to copy
I'm sure it's not going to be a doctor I'm
not going
yeah I was watching you around my secondary
monitor muted it's been watching you
I think I love your scarf by the way I want
a scarf like that
yeah so
yeah here we go so this is the form of the
physical activity requirements
ice a thing
did she trick my truck tomorrow I got to buy
my wife will make it a short usually
I'm supposed to be going away now I just
can't sleep
we're talking to hackers in end of the world
through cybersecurity I really need to pick
up Q I have been trying to figure it out I
just want to lose I saw your thing somebody
was saying he was one of the things for
infrastructure everybody needs to learn what
is the Q language
see if he has the language in Rainier Valley
and Cassadaga
I think of something I know that uses Q
these real sci-fi yeah it depends on what
you mean by that but I think yes
do you mean like 2001 A Space Odyssey or
something
what is q q configure UniFi execute
I sure got a problem so right ice ice for
that
I probably reading is that I read so much
during the day that I have a hard time
reading at night I guess I go on vacation I
love her either if I read in the tub
my boy I got a new toy thank you
you're the only book I have thought about
that audio books there. I am really
it's kind of scary though hey that's why
they have a boring page cuz it a big fancy
ass graphic
I can't find a pharmacy nice
nice I have to mention it and so now I'm
kind of interested
it's like you're at it's a list yeah it was
looking like darker
yeah he was telling me to look at bought
feels good too and I don't know if I want to
like you is the language of app delivery and
it's a list of languages we had when we were
talking about we're talking to all the
scripting languages I was writing
okay running a summary of stuff for the
infrastructure boost
and we're like What are the shell languages
we have to learn
like the next 15 shell bash Python
Programming. I think we were like going
through all the configuration languages like
HCL yamo you know we go for opa
it's not it's not until really interesting
interesting that is interesting so if you
have an attentive I January 12th I fuck
that's like brand new
I got a document this give me a sec ice I
need to read
but it's new on here read up read up on cue
but I like I keep
hearing about this new language out there
how to get proficient in understanding
what it is about a family of languages
so now it's in my list of tissues all right
so entertain your favorite container Tech
Chancellor Sears something upon Q language
since its share this right soul and Kelsey
talked about it and Prometheus and she's
really so much revitalization language
tutorials really occupy herself on Hikes and
when I seen you that the delivery system
only minutes after I Q I don't know but that
we're not going to be writing manifest files
and Q are we
are we how to change the topic
all right give me a sec
they were back in science and technology
with her with her friends all right so
you think it I didn't think they were
yelling was going to have a competitor for
that shit that's interesting
never come pick you up I see how much Asa
really wow
wow I'm glad I thought I checked into your
stream
Fallout doctor room if you haven't everybody
I don't have a way to do that
yes we got really
well I mean I wouldn't all right all right
all right all right I got to read the Sun
just so you know at least at least keep
hearing about it so we were just I was just
having to refresh my room because of agren
and I'm like I wonder if they could write
that kind of thing you know
I got most of the stuff you stuff in the
world communities they just principles price
predecessor Borg Michelle and board Forge
will be sailing on a generalization to
Google configuration language
vanlue look who's in the go team so it's big
and go then huh
yes thanks for that kick you out of an
aquarius creator
security came in Denver
unless your programming language promise to
be useful for configuration is this mean
that when I can have to go to HCL cuz I
don't want to I don't like a seal I love how
she acquired but I can't get my head I don't
like a seal I made the time will go by the
way
let's get this
thank you I'm sorry it's like it's stopping
me from going to terraform is it really
is a fortune to go can fire you gotta be
kidding me are you fucking kidding me
I didn't know I'm really intrigued dude I
have study the internals to go compile a lot
that's what you guys if you want to learn
how to make a computer for yourself or land
right even your own parser and scanner which
I want to do cuz I did pay
I probably put a plug in for Megan
I mean it's it's sloppy right now but I
thought I was writing that I did that Chi
versus Jason
really oh I know this great excuse is so
secretive in a definite logic program
oh boy look at you yeah
yes I want to put that on here add it to my
list
I think of a front-end meridians karamazov
missing it really wow
white another king from a spiritual and
social cues human in 10 minutes
4 bus I don't put up with is going to be the
new cool hotness
which is Json schema can bite me I hate it
and then look at you and your lips of
awesome links well I shall continue
ISO continue in my documentation of such
links or on behalf of the community
set is that chat last are you
but if anybody wants to keep track
is there Transformer two different codex oh
my God for all of that guide
increase rate accused. Pronunciation of
Charlotte competitions
and other don'ts yeah
the Q DSL you shouldn't focus on miss me if
the clarity of okay
text me spreadsheet it is so everything's in
there such kind of cute teen looks
I mean but I'm so not remember you been I've
been playing around with this
I saw your plane around are you what's a
echo is Echo accutool
is accurate probably
is there a cute library for python
hexagon the rest of my work did not know
that
I did not know that I had was a friend of
mine without a paddle and a Swagger but
and does not look right how do I learn
python for finance also doesn't look right
here seeking to pages
Henderson Harbor ice for Q
wow somebody's re-written Hardware
interfaces and Q Irish bars
can you shoot the same thing
I smell python specific stuff
enter mask is off soanswer my excuse off
somehow I don't know how I want what's up
with masks
all right Turnpike you nice
I can become all the weather Hank is ready
to go already makes me
that's Mission if I could at 4 from the
compiler that makes me love it more do the
Empire is a fucking work of art it is a work
of art
it's so amazing oh that's the one
I should probably just leave this open y'all
are providing awesome links here this is
what we call Cole earning
colored a hashtag learning
and it's like come to guys like a big
I'm leaving soap and now cuz I knew it was
coming I knew it was to take him to go get
power
holyshit
color name tag
the others co-working I'm very proud to say
that some of the people in our community
Lobby to have co-working added go Dash
working it's now a tag so officially attack
so that's fun
I haven't seen a cradle made daughter a
deployment some of the biggest planes in the
moment
that mean I smoke right now Gamers I said
hell yeah doctor if you have any pull at all
are you partner
I think people give a shit about me they
hate me
suffer tekates Me Like Loving against me
okay fine to provide an alternative to the
scripts
Brandon triche seriously
I'm so sad I saw go in your name I was like
I do Kona go on here somewhat I'm just been
talking about how soft my Coast Hills
getting cuz I've been doing all this crazy
stuff. True or false is going to put you on
the spot true or false you should go so you
can understand qbdm as I as committed as
I've been making the case overwhelmingly
that people should learn go if they wanted
to claw date of stuff at all even if their
operations people so they can read the
source code when the documentation fails
them they can go read the source code and go
haha that's what it's doing I did that for
him he will no helmet charts Argo templates
keep telling people this is why you should
look up Nick and if you want to get it
operations his operations is synonymous with
communities these days it's not always been
you know it's more or less
yeah
what's good if it's good that you're
streaming I hopefully you will still stay
streaming and figure your your your figure
your thing out
I don't like it out add cubed she'll find
any more agreed with one and go from Tecate
to yeah yes
I think it's I think it's true
so I maintain I maintain that the best way
rather than you Kelsey Hightower hard way
the best way to truly understand how
coronavirus works is to read the source code
of Cuba ATM and go through Cuba ATM and do
each face at a time and by the way if you're
interested in that I have an entire vagrant
thing that I set up just to do that very
thing the kick-off point to get you all of
it the notes provision to be M locally so
that you can do your own Covidien installs
and practice at going to be I'm going to be
speedrunning that shit over the next week or
so because because I need to certify and
also I need to do some tests some sort of
class of ship
yeah if you look at it's my lab I don't know
if that lives been posted we just did we
just finished the vagrant the NFS loud
this was this is freaking awesome yeah I'm
super proud of this one this gives you a
three node A3 machine collection with NFS
configured and set up on the top one so it's
ready to it's ready to to put committees on
top of if you if you want that one
this display
yeah yeah I want to do it I mean I put it on
my calendar so Saturdays in particular
I've been doing boo stuff right so we're
going to do containers of kubernetes
February 12th to the 30th and then another
big one here I need to certify before July
cuz I bought I bought all the tests and then
we're going to do the next week in a recent
May 4th and infrastructure engineering
witches
baby stuff I know if you know but I've been
I've been doing
mentary for years the company that I started
to do men shrink but now I might try to
catch up because so much shit went down
since I started the company
apparently yes
I kind of want to go see Q samples human
definition
it's like I've been I switched over to the
alma for a Red Hat Linux stuff cuz I'm
instead of a because you know Enterprise is
all red hat Road about that and I'm like
oh goody selinux I was very happy to find
a very very happy to find somebody found
this for us today while we were doing our
work
as we have to find a firewall see if you
came and I did not know about this
the save me a ton of time and they belong in
the face of the ways it would have been a
bunch of shit or PC in Ableton
chunky chunky sweater are pretty veteran
members here and chunky had said that Elmo's
way better than stream news flash light of
us because it doesn't have as many bugs that
has been fixed to turn around because route
faster I haven't had I haven't been
monitoring just Rosa picking the Enterprise
distros for a long time and we have a ton of
people in our community here who are senior
Architects and University house and stuff
like that or making this kind of decision
all the time and date they overwhelming and
they said Elam has a way to go and I'm in
Rocky and where they waited to get a true
sent to us without sent to us or true
redhead without red on my hosting for my BMI
if I still use coarse thread he's a bunch of
her that when I need when I'm doing from
scratch containers of stuff
but yeah this is soup is this is what we did
today
do it in today we did run it for business
Krypton allocate assistance up in an FS
amount in like 10 lines of code
and it's all they do not interact with I
have never this is the first time I've ever
scripted the creation of partition and I've
always done it through interactive
interacting with fdisk and I don't know I
didn't know part of very well
yeah GTA this way I know a lot of people do
yeah the reason I'm not into the UK and the
other Cloud providers it because I'm
responsible for managing on Prime cluster
this guy to know Calico installed and it
self storage classes and it you know that
you have to know middle of me and all these
things that you don't have to install it on
me and grass and you know I have to figure
out how long balancing most people will will
just turn to the clouds of that kind of
thing in my case though I definitely don't
want to do that because I can't test filling
filling a storage class underlying you know
NFS volume now I can't do that in the cloud
you can't do it because if you don't have
access to it so that's the case where you
wanted you from scratch you want to do your
own you have bootstrap your Uncle Randy's in
a way that you can that's pretty
yeah
I mean that's what they pay me for these
days just to keep the system running and we
blew up Domino's Domino's application when
we filled the underlying
NFS mount with with with disc in the whole
thing without and don't know what to monitor
it because criticism care about how close
you're going to fill discus no way to
measure it and so I'm trying to write motors
for that and talk to icing go which is pain
in the ass but
necessary schema definition as I hear we
have some Q
it actually uses a hashtag wow
interesting shit
has the comparative stuff in his declaration
hello
hello be careful he pays a hashtag
well I'm going to get used to oh well yeah
yeah I had to do a W-2 job because I need
insurance
truth be told I'm kind of glad I did a
person to learn all the stuff
typos constraint as a concrete all in the
same space, Atlantis really wow
that is a fun rabbit hole right here this is
a really fun rabbit hole
is he okay oh my God
oh my God this is so cool
whoa
it
I am not doing Json schema Json schema can
fight me
fucking hate it I have that lots of fuel I
didn't put it in my thing I guess I didn't
I didn't the logic of cue the logic of queue
no relation to the Next Generation Star Trek
character oh God
it chilling yeah
copy I got a r s
thank you everybody for all your your input
on that
I obviously have something to learn about in
case in case you were wondering you have to
learn stuff in tack all the time every day
every week and if you stop learning you die
that's all
Emma is not true it's true right
I hate you know what my favorite dude my
favorite
my favorite quote on that is mr. Leon
learning with Leon who's this you know as
well as well boot camp he calls it.
Engineering weekend whenever my favorite
coat on that is that choosing a technical
career is a lifestyle choice I love that
quote I want to like I want to like frame
that quote and put it on my wall
a very well fuck yeah
I love that quote it's just so good because
it's it perfectly covers it if you choose to
go into Tech you are automatically signing
on to a regular intense amount of learning
every week and if you stop doing it you will
die you cannot survive and if you don't
believe me just talked to anybody who's
running the people who stop learning because
they're resting on their Laurels inside of a
Tech Career particularly inside of my being
or something like that
he will die for my not watching my
coursesprobably true commander commander
it's probably true
you're a dummy but I just think it's like
you you you have to keep feeding yourself
new information and also you have to be able
to manage it that's why I cut all the stuff
I did in my calendar or just now because
it's like
a s n i b a l my God I was in a meeting for
15 years so I can tell you all kinds can I
explain
and that the rate of change in the any
technical career is so fast affecting the
web world that a term that was invented by
Webb tax called framework fatigue
and there was a there was a time that I went
back bone and and and get her and Amber and
and all the Frameworks were or what's up
why are people doing sleep streams
because it's fun I did to sleep streams yeah
I took a nap on stream was just cuz it's
just to be cool
I'm at the fuck I'm tired I'm going to sleep
and leave my mic video on I turn my sound
down so Casey no
I mean I don't know what people just want to
feel connected right now and then he will do
anything to do it
they will
I think I'm particularly lucky because I do
have a family this with me pretty much all
the time for better or worse right
and down
that makes me think I need to call my kids
again actually because it's so easy to get
disconnected and lonely
and humans eat other humans no matter how
reclusive we think we are we need him and
sometimes just seeing somebody you know
I imagine there's at least one person out
there that has somebody else sleeping on a
big screen and they're just sleeping in
their bed and their couch next to them just
so they can feel like there they got another
person in the room
and I don't I don't disparage that at all I
think that's totally fine
and CeCe stinks I said marriage there I
don't yet this version
is there hacking is a martial art newcomers
of this is a stupid phone, which thing not
stupid just
Madison Middle School and on that note I
think I'm going to bed, should we read she
read somebody
I got into this whole dating thing I have a
hard time getting into it
but it is a thing
gotobus the resume I know what
oh yeah
yeah we never come out at all there's always
tons to we learned right
hey I was really nobody on her now
what day is it is it Sunday
it's Sunday morning right I sleep I haven't
by have a bimodal sleep schedule
redeem a security girl I think it probably
does too if you're lonely
yeah I can see how that I I really hope my
kids don't feel that way cuz I can call him
actually I'm calling tomorrow to call my
boys tomorrow I don't call him very much I'm
a very hands-off parent better or worse
sleeping I'm Only Sleeping waking up at 11
a.m. are you talking about Frying Pan live
I think they got it looks like they got did
you see this
and somebody I think this is what you're
asking for
a frying pan on the odd chance of actually
watching us and if I'm people watching you
sleep
I love it it's crazy which is funny
since it's pretty funny that's why I love it
though oh mr. security light
that's why she's adding it oh my God
I feel cozy yeah me too Iron Man run
who is following me hey Will butcher how are
you
they just egg ads
Avail is string you got to love it set up
though is crazy I set up
his room is room so messy as awesome houses
on nobody I know
oh wait who's this oh since it's a yes
oh hey supposed to answer should I watch the
pole dancing she is so talented
books to read the full dancer the Russian
pole dancer
we're going to do. Have you seen her do
before you say anything you have to fucking
watch her she's so talented she is amazing
about it yes but she's also extremely
talented
leotards no brother don't read the pole
dancer I'll come on it's in those come
she she
hope this is just creepy.
Daddy yet
fell in love now I'm already a conditioner
Russia versus Germany
okie dokie this will be fun she'll just
think I'm like a dirty old man as usual
since when has that stopped me before I will
tell you I am a dirty old man
that way when I get home and I get some
pizza like I told you to
abortion in the The National another kind of
natural pencil.
Just chatting start to trade third grade
no honey boo boo
banana banana slicer
now that is keep them in your system
let's go to the store what is it the one
thing when you are another
it was nice time see everybody